well hello uh hello everybody welcome to
the show
welcome to 2021 and uh we're about to
get into
the i'm not a gm tournament i'm your
host
grandmastermon hamilton and i'm joined
by andrea botes my co-host for today hi
andrea
hello guys how's it going i'm on pretty
good pretty good
i'm feeling great this morning i have to
admit i'm starting off 2021
waking up earlier than i ever did in
me too actually i've been trying to put
in some healthier habits so
yeah let's make 20 21 off to a good
start
yep yep cheers to that um and this
tournament
is probably one of the more exciting
ones for me i i just love like these
entertaining type of events that
chess.com puts on it's the i'm
not a gm tournament and as i like to
describe it
it's people in this tournament are
talented enough that
it's really really high level chess that
people can follow
but there's also enough blenders that i
think it makes it highly entertaining
yeah i think the speed matches are the
most fun and i'm especially excited
because my sister will be competing and
we were training
together yesterday to beat greg but now
she's on her own so
curious to see how she's gonna do up
against greg yeah and you've you've just
uh highlighted the match up and that's
uh exactly right today it's gonna be
international master
greg shahadi facing off against uh
women's feuding master alexandra botez
and you mentioned that she's gonna be on
her own today you've done maybe some
some
sister prep the other day but uh the
interesting thing about this match
uh people can already uh guess there is
a rating mismatch greg is the
the favorite by rating and so alexandra
is starting with 15 points handicapped
so she starts the match up 15-0
and then the match is basically a race
can greg you know collect those 15
points and then some
over the course of the match or is
alexandra just gonna run away with it so
what do you think of this odds format
which is the kind of the first time
we've seen this in this tournament and
in these match formats i think it's
going to be very interesting because
alex especially that's why she was
trying to memorize those lines because
the rating gap was so
different so i'm really curious if this
will make it equal odds or not
yep so we'll have to see about that guys
uh and we'll be reminding you throughout
the event about that
that handicap but keep that in mind uh
alexander starts with 15 points and
and with that let's let's jump into the
you know precise format
of this match and the entire uh uh i'm
not a gm tournament so um as you can see
the the main bracket is just
single elimination knockout which you'll
be familiar is the style for these
uh speedchest championship type of
matches and
speaking of those scc formats uh it's
going to have
a five plus one blitz time control
there's gonna be a three plus one
blitz time control and one plus one
bullet chest so uh first of all andrea
what do you think of those three formats
does that make it
like a pretty pretty balanced match do
you think either player
will have an advantage in one of these
controls yeah i'm really
excited for you know the last few bullet
matches um
i think the blitz i don't know i don't
watch too many
um speed tournaments so it's always very
interesting because alex for example
her big strength is bullet and dirty
flagging i don't know if
greg will be as speedy but that's my
favorite part of speedchest the very
last few
quick seconds and minutes yep yep and
that is probably going to be very very
important for
the match overall i mean i think
alexandra would be maybe a lot happier
if she could get
75 minutes of bullet chest instead of
yeah the set of the 25 minutes that
uh they've got there but we'll see how
that plays out but you guys will be very
familiar with that format from
previous editions and um well as you can
see the winner of the match advances to
the next bracket and
what are these guys competing for well
let's talk a quick sec about the prizes
um these guys are competing for ten
thousand dollars
in prizes uh in total there's the round
of 16
there's the quarterfinals the semifinals
and the finals and you can see
the breakdown there the winner the round
of 16
250 dollars and then they advance to the
quarterfinals and
the other interesting thing is that uh
the rest of the money is split by
win percentage so uh all i'm seeing
based on this andrea is that uh your
sister
she's already starting out with some
money she's got 15 points on the board
yeah she has some pretty good chances
here to win some nice prize money
so that's not too bad um everyone is
gonna have a good time get a good match
and then obviously if you progress
in this tournament you collect more and
more prizes um
so let's take a quick look at the
bracket as well you're probably
wondering you know this sounds like an
exciting matchup to start things off
brag against alexandra but uh who else
do we have
in this tournament and as you can see
from the bracket here
you know have a lot of names that you
might recognize from maybe the previous
edition of
the i'm not a gm tournament but there
are also some names that
i think people will be more familiar
andrea from just the streaming world
um yeah how that's changed so many names
stand out there to you that you
recognize
of course almost almost all of them i
was going to say
we have erica rosen we have even some
younger girls getting into streaming
like carissa yip
a less alessia who's been streaming for
a long time
obviously levy lots of big streamers
here that i'm very excited to see
yeah and of course we can't forget danny
wrench
i was gonna say you know he's easily
forgettable but
he is he is in the tournament and he's
uh
facing off against lawrence trent as you
can see over there so
i know there's a lot of levy fans uh in
the chat as i can see
um so he's gonna have a match up against
james canty as well
there's as you mentioned a lot of other
streamers so i think it's just gonna be
a nice
mix of players that were in the last
edition of tournament plus a lot of new
streamers
uh that that a lot of people are fans of
yeah
it'd be a lot of fun do you think the
streamers will have a higher
percentage of wins mainly because
they're more
used to speed chess and bullet well
as a streamer myself andrea i'd like to
think that that's the case you know we
streamers we got to stick together so we
need some
some advantage at least here's to hoping
here's to hoping that we can just uh
let's us streamers we have an advantage
somewhere in speeches
exactly yeah so i'm definitely uh
definitely secretly rooting for some
some streamers to do well but
you know as as everyone can see there
from the bracket
uh you know a lot of your favorites are
gonna be in this event um it's a
pretty long long event uh many matches
so
uh there'll be lots of lots of time to
cheer for
your favorites yeah anything can happen
we have like three hours of
of speech so lots of games today
yep um and the game should be starting
in in a couple of minutes
uh andrea we can see the the players are
on cam what do you make of the
let's call it the first impression we
got alexandra and greg
uh who who sort of wins the the outfit
battle so far i have to say
every time i i did one match actually
where me and greg
we're a team against alex and he always
pulls out these hats i'm a big fan of
the hats
so i say he's the winner just for his
nice hat game
and are you saying that while watching
your sister
do some curls there um yeah because
i i mean alexander is really trying to
win over the hearts of the crowd right
now
she came into my room asking for the
dumbbell and i didn't really understand
how it would come into use into the
the speed match but you know preparing
you know like they say a healthy body
healthy mind so
very important every doesn't every don't
you do this before every chess match
well i was gonna say the fact that your
sister came in
early in the morning and said can i can
i grab the dumbbell for my speed chest
match and you didn't find that weird
i i think that just goes to show how
normal things are
you know in the bow tez household there
yes of course
um but i i agree i like the uh i like
the hat from from greg
uh although all i see on the scoreboard
right now is the guy's down 15 points he
seems
pretty confident for a guy's uh getting
crushed in this match so far
yeah then i'm curious what he i'm gonna
enter when we interview him i'm very
curious what he thinks about this
because originally this was this was the
last minute well not very last minute
change but
i thought alex could maybe even take him
on without the point odds so who said
maybe she doesn't need it or maybe
that's just the
the natural born hustler in her she she
knew she knew she could take greg and
she
pretended she hustled away exactly she
needed some 15 points so
that's like not bad at all but yeah it
is a points odds match we're
starting with 15 points uh for alexandra
and then the rest of the match just
proceeds
and scores normally
see the chat is already uh already on
that 15 points
so we'll we'll see i i think that it is
going to make things more exciting
um at the end of the day greg is the um
the stronger player
but yeah as you mentioned alexandra very
very tricky
and very used to streaming and playing
online so hopefully that that
pays off here yeah i like tease a bit i
mean greg
is do you know his rating alex was
telling me he's around 2700
which would be a huge rating gap so
in the end i do think it's pretty fair
but you know of course i'm gonna cheer
on alex a little bit
yup no this is a completely unbiased
commentary booth
absolutely there's nothing to see here
greg definitely has a very high rating
on chess.com and
uh he was in the previous edition of uh
the
i am not a gm tournament and i think he
uh he made it to
probably i think it was at least the
semi-finals so he's he's definitely one
of the favorites to do well here but
looks like he's having a good time he's
got the got the hat on and he seems to
be uh
in good spirits yeah greg is always very
positive when i played with him as my
teammate it was so much fun
he's very positive she keeps his head up
the entire match even if you're
even when we're losing a few games and
with that attitude we've managed to pull
a win
so i think it was all because of greg
yep
yep and how's the how's the chat feeling
about our
our competitors here do they agree with
you that that
greg won the outfit battle maybe there's
maybe there's more alexandra fans in
chat i'm not sure but
um you know we have to judge this fairly
who's going to win the match but
also right now yeah i see we have a poll
going on and
oh most of the chat thinks 15 points
might be too much of a handicap but
i don't know greg is pretty strong they
might be underestimating him
yep well the one thing about uh people
have to remember about the
five minute portion andrea is that it
actually goes really slowly right like a
five minute game with one second
increment don't forget guys
it can actually go like you know 15
minutes for for one game
so that portion can really take a long
time i think that greg is comfortable
with this handicap
because he's hoping to make it up in
bullet so if he's wrong about that
then it could he could be totally wrong
for the match yeah
not even bullet one thing we were
discussing yesterday when alex and i
were training with hammer
was like even when he would get in
better position straight from the
opening
with greg's experience in the longer
time control he could probably easily
outplay
in the end game so i think even in a
longer time control
he's even more favored yep and and i've
just been told kind of a funny
funny bit of information that it was
actually suggested that
the the let's say the handicap instead
of 15 it was actually supposed to be 12
points
and then greg was like 12 points you got
to be kidding me and he said make it 15.
so that's a little bit of confidence
from greg johnson go chat
yeah everyone's saying that it's too
much of a handicap no greg is feeling
confident about this
yeah he wanted this he wanted the uh
i like the confidence yep
that's good and i think that the uh yeah
that's a big
big alpha move there by uh by greg
yeah we'll see if you'll regret it maybe
those three points will be decisive who
knows
and i'm just following the players here
because you know what uh andrea the
games
have uh just got underway i'm so excited
for these games because
we studied these lines and greg has some
like favorite
sidelines that are very weird i'm
curious if he's gonna play into them but
we'll see let's uh i mean i i heard
something
over the last uh couple sentences you
mentioned someone by the name of hammer
that's a pretty serious uh bit of
preparation that alexandra must have
been doing for this match
oh yeah she doesn't remember her lines
hammer would be very disappointed
he was very he took his because this was
some preparation he had from a few years
ago oh and greg
okay so so far greg has been playing
exactly into the line that hammer
prepared
so it's very interesting yep so you know
what guys this is going to be one of our
segments during the commentary we're
gonna go to uh andrea for the
uh botez opening phase analysis and
she's gonna let us know
whether or not alexandra should have any
clue what's going on here and you're
saying so far
this is actually something that she's
maybe prepared well
okay knight b6 was um
is it's a stray from the books so now no
more hammer lines
just fluffed alex but alex should
already have the advantage
and there's this e5 move right away from
alexandria
i'll just describe it as well it may be
a very good move but i'll just say it's
very committal
uh it gains a lot of space it pushes
black's pieces back but at the same time
one of the things you always have to be
careful of is white's king is in the
middle
and hasn't castled yet is at least a few
moves away
greg with the black pieces has already
castled so
anytime you start advancing you worry
about maybe getting too overextended
uh in the opening so that's the only
risk here for alexandra and she's
already taken on d6
yeah if oh i guess she couldn't
i i guess you could have defended it
actually hmm
like knight f3 instead yeah yeah i was
considering knight f3 but
now night on h3 now it's not always a
bad move but when you see a move like
that
you know that the person who's playing
with the white piece is doing it
intentionally because
knight f3 was available but she said no
i want the knight on h3
she's clearly remembering something
maybe the hammer
said one time and one call he's like hey
alexander put the knight on h3 it's good
here
what do you think of that move so one
idea was that she
didn't push h3 which was a main idea in
this position
so that she could use that square for a
knight but that doesn't mean that it was
correct in this position i'm not sure
i was thinking maybe she's eyeing that
two squares so she doesn't have holes
around her king but
do you think knight h3 was stronger than
knight f3
uh i have to say with the open e file
i'm inclined to say no
and i was just highlighting this on the
board that the c pawn was actually
hanging there
because of the pin and what alexander
was probably counting on
was that after bishop takes g7 if the
king took back
she actually has this great queen d4
move hitting the knight in the king no
but i think i think after that oh my
goodness after queen d4 we've seen the
first
bow tez gambit what a way to start off i
would not be proud alex amber would not
be proud of this game
i don't know what i think she played way
too quickly
like she played all these moves so fast
and obviously greg's tactical
calculations a little bit better
but you know i think she just wanted to
start you know with an iconic
botez gambit it was just for content she
didn't actually miss the tactics
definitely not uh this is not a scripted
match
alexandra definitely just going for
content here and
honestly andrea i just couldn't think of
a
more a better way to start the match
better win yeah
exactly and now she's going to win every
game now that you know she shows off her
signature
and how the real play comes in yeah
yeah and and something tells me that uh
like
basically a bow ties gambit at this
point is almost like a 50 50 if it's
going to happen
honestly greg did not look that
surprised he was like okay yeah one of
those
yeah well alex was flying back face
falling so
that's very interesting okay well we're
on to the next game it is
uh although it's one nothing in the
match don't forget that handicap
that's a part of this match because of
the rating difference so it's 15
to one right now greg has made the first
strides in closing that
that 15 game uh gap and right now greg
is playing the
roxy bind which is characterized by this
pawn structure right here
and from my experience with the moroxy
bind generally it's it's a really
comfortable position
to play for white you have more space at
some point you can get this knight into
d5 and alexander is going to be playing
with a kind of
cramped uh position with not a lot of
space is this
a position that you think she should be
pretty familiar with though andre
yeah so we studied moroxybine because
this was the opening
i was going to play i play the hypixel
dragon but actually greg already
castling is not
um the best move for white because white
can
black can easily attack on his queen
side so
i think greg it might be um
yeah it's about equal so i think he's
giving his advantage a little bit
he was about to castle king's side and
leave his rooks on the queen side
exactly like it's a little more uh
natural i think for most chess players
in general to castle king's side
greg here has castle queen side which
honestly looks a little strange maybe to
to most people watching because it's
like
it looks like alexander's already got
this attack on
on the queen side but look how many
pieces have been traded off already
and all of a sudden greg says oh hang on
hang on it's my turn to attack
yeah trading off the bishops was very
interesting because
you know now it's more likely to go into
the end game position unless he's going
for it for the king attack
which looks a little bit scary but
normally this trade should be okay for
black
yeah so it basically if the queens uh
disappeared from the board
imagine that then i think alexandra
should be very happy
she gets that nice night on on c5 so
because of that
white uh greg in this case should really
look to keep the queens on and go
for the king yeah that is black's goal
here to try to trade queens and go into
then game
and i'll just play a bad move for a
second uh f5 just to show what alexandra
maybe is
dreaming of she wants a position where
her knight can choose from these
beautiful dark squares
and everything's locked up over here
there's no way to get to her king
i don't know if she's gonna get that i
don't think greg is gonna be so kind i
don't think greg
that's what she wants um so how would
you look to
to break through here alexandra is kind
of playing in a weird way she's going
for that sturdy
formation almost like a fortress um how
would you try to break through here with
uh with greg's position with the white
pieces well
do you think trading on g5 would be a
good idea
well it's an interesting question first
of all if uh alexander took back with
the h
pawn then i would say maybe yes good
idea because we get to push that pawn up
the board
this bishop on yep might get in there
with uh with f5 and most of all the h
file would be open so maybe
uh maybe greg could use that so i would
say after this
alexander would be looking to take back
with the f pawn she just pushed
open up the file and then be able to put
that knight on e5 so i would say no
this pawn keeping the knight out of the
e5 square
that's exactly what what i think is good
about greg's position so i'd probably be
looking to keep it there
maybe go like g3 so that i always have a
pawn on f4 and
i was about to mention okay bishop to g4
and start to use some of those weakened
light squares
yeah alexandra that's what i was gonna
say
the weak color complexes
i mean at least one benefit for alex is
that all her pawns are in black and she
has a light scored bishop which if she
does get out of this mess and trade
could be to our advantage but white is
occupying the light squares which are
all weaknesses around the king
yep very well said um and this is
exactly why
these pawns on dark squares and light
square bishop that's exactly what i
mentioned earlier
if this goes to an end game i think
alexandra is is favored immediately
so as soon as those queens disappear end
game you're happy to have the pawns uh
the opposite color of your bishop
whereas these white pawns here it's
fixed on a light square it's the same
color as your bishop
you get to an end game with this guy
he's going to be able to attack that
pawn and white's only being able to
defend so
that's why i think greg is going to be
focused on keeping the queens
on the board alexandra definitely
looking for an end game
exactly here i think it's a little bit
hard for alex to play because
white has pretty obvious plan to attack
but for her
there's not yet a clear plan what would
you think is
the best plan for black here to defend
or attack
yeah there's a there is kind of an idea
um which is maybe a little weird but
you actually want to maybe take the pawn
on f4
with pawn on g5 in order to give
yourself the e5 square
so you sort of secure that square for
the knight by taking the pawn and
that's why i was mentioning the last
turn g3 as a potential for white so that
that couldn't happen
and now as a result queen a5 greg says
you know what it's my time to strike
i'm going in the center with e5 powerful
move if pawn takes
e5 well the d-pawn takes e5 he's trying
to
take on d7 and if the f-bomb takes e5
he's trying to take then on g5 this is a
wild move
from greg uh do you think it caught
alexander off guard
um yes but i don't know i'm not
following the e value but i don't know
for the best idea i have a question if
if
black takes on e5 and white takes the
knight could he play something like rook
d8
yep like to pin the uh yeah trying to
win the bishop back
definitely definitely the probably the
in this position i would say
i don't think that can be necessarily
stopped trying to think of a
night maneuver that might help here um
always got to be watching when these
queens are facing each other
some some kind of night maneuver but no
that that actually looks like
kind of a reasonable the computer
doesn't like it i think white's still
better in that position but using the
pin there seems very reasonable
f5 by alexandra though hitting the
bishop with tempo
once the bishop moves then she can start
thinking about
taking those those pawns in the center
but right now be careful
you take there you still lose the knight
to a tactic yes
she could also try to be blocking up the
position maybe
g4 do you think it's better if she tries
to escape the pressure
and leaving white's attack on her g5
pawn or should she push and try to
keep blocking yeah that's the main issue
here is that
there's f takes g5 which i think is a
huge threat probably the
most dangerous thing in the position
yeah white taking on d6
is honestly not as scary as white taking
on g5 so
um in this position even if you take on
f3
um this this is going to get open the g
file gets open so
i think if the g file gets open
alexander might just get checkmated
she's down a minute let's not forget
about that
as well um yeah this is a tough position
already
i mean i i think it's clear that black
doesn't really have any way that she can
defend the g5 pawn so
i feel like moves like here she should
play quickly because g4 seems a little
bit forced
yep yeah i think it is also uh a line of
thought where you maybe take on
g5 let that happen let let the
white pieces take on h6 as well and then
hide your king uh but at this point i
think alexandra has to make some
concessions
she has to do some yeah at least
for so she's not wasting
too much time already down a whole
minute
yeah and at this point she might
consider a move that
doesn't look that great maybe e6 just to
keep things closed
um taking on d6 though i think might be
the way to go
and and then just put the knight on on
f6 afterwards yeah e6 and
all we can say is white's up a pawn and
it's right there on d6 yeah looking
pretty strong
it's a very uncomfortable position that
pass fawn is very strong and
her king is very exposed very hard to
defend here
yep no at this point i think uh i think
greg's
even got ideas like rook takes e6 uh
like i
haven't calculated that one up fully but
i wouldn't be surprised if
it was a half decent move i think it's
not necessary for greg because he's up
so much time
he's up upon no need to maybe go crazy
unless you're sure there's a win
but just the idea of taking followed by
maybe like a queen check and queen down
to e7
to take that knight um maybe some
checkmate ideas
this oh he didn't go for it i thought he
was gonna go for it i thought it looked
pretty promising
but i guess he can just prepare it oh i
like what alexandra is doing she's
playing quick
both of her last two moves were
attacking moves towards the king that's
what you want to see but
it might be just be too little too late
with 19 seconds
yeah she's trying to create some sort of
counter play some attack on the king
maybe
hoping he'll miss something in her time
pressure but i think
now that she's let that deep on free
there has to be a forced win coming up
pretty soon
yeah the thing is once you uh you don't
sacrifice
on e6 the first time you're not about to
do it the second time
right so i don't think greg is really on
that uh
that sacrifice uh kind of idea anymore
and uh
hang on i mean queen b6 b2 pawn is
always pressured here
the knight does guard the e6 pawn yeah
she's just finding a way to hold up
hang on knight d3 something at least
signs of life here b2 is hit
both the rooks and the queen are a hit
so i think we're gonna see an exchange
yeah i don't think greg can save his
exchange but
let's give credit to alexandra she she
made a game out of this for sure
1984 i think was probably the move there
not played
and all of a sudden alexandra flipping
this game around
oh my goodness that is definitely what
she is best at under time pressure even
a completely loss
and that's something she always tries to
teach me to find any attack
and put as much pressure and seem like
it's working for her now he's in time
pressure
yep and we've seen we have i think we
haven't seen dragon time pressure
so let's go alexandra i think
thought she blundered but she didn't
yeah i don't know what she was reacting
to
she thought she missed knight a4 forking
the rooks but
she would have taken it with check she
thought she blundered that's the that's
well she's playing great right now
andrea i don't know she's got five
seconds
she's gotta focus up now we're gonna see
who's really better in the end game
except with this immense pressure take
that pawn
oh rook f3 is a great move as well but
even if she sacrifices here
i think she's got it she's playing
really really well right now
this is a great save she's found
now she has to be careful of knight a4
knight c5 oh no what are these
oh no alexander oh no
those two pawns are connected i spoke
too soon
oh my goodness did we jinxer
yeah we may have oh man it was hard to
spawn under time pressure but
yeah the knight c5 was brutal wow
she had such a nice save too yep
but at least you know she can it seems
like greg obviously a little bit sharper
at tactics but
seems like she can play pretty equally
in the end game
well it it has to be said that alexander
basically clawed her way
back from yes a dead lost position and
that's already a really good sign
for the alexandra fans out there that if
she if she can do that
she's she's not going to have a hard
time what is
up with that move well what
is happening okay uh okay i don't know
what i'm uh
seeing here yeah i don't really know
what's gonna think white's still winning
no that was the winning
incredible it was weird it was almost
equal for for a little bit
oh and there goes the rook okay
well it was like you said i think this
gives us a lot of hope for the future
matches
uh yeah sorry i'm just getting used to
it except for the
very last few moves whoa okay
andrea a lot to a lot to take in there
but uh
good things all around if you're team
alexandra in that yes
um greg did show a few sides of weakness
there he's been very
consistent but maybe a few things that
we finally noticed that he's not
invincible in these time scrambles
and and alexandra really did hang in
there in a position that
uh honestly i might have given up sooner
than she did she played year yeah
i was a fan of that i don't know if greg
was maybe getting too confident in the
win
because he's normally seeing those type
of tactics and he had so many winning
tactics there so we'll see if maybe
he'll be a little bit more careful with
his winning advantage yeah i think greg
um
uh needed to to maybe go for that
sacrifice you remember that
sacrifice that we were talking about so
maybe now that
you know we're in a new game he might
reflect on that and feel like he needs
to play more aggressive
in general yeah we'll see if that
changes in the match especially when he
has the win
but yeah so i see we got into the same
position they got into in their first
game
yeah and this knight b6 move you
mentioned like hey this is kind of a
weird
you know off the book move but that's
exactly what good preparation is
sometimes you know your opponent
is preparing against you and you're
saying look i'm not going to play the
best move in this position i'm not going
to play the most common move
i'm going to play a move that you've
probably never seen before because i
know that you haven't prepared for it
yeah i think i think that yeah his
correct idea is
e6 um and that was what alex had
prepared
his knight b6 why it throws her off i
don't know how much i like it for black
because i feel like his knight doesn't
really have anywhere to go the c4 pawn
is defended
he doesn't have a four square so i don't
know how good the b6 square is in
general
oh yep um i think what we're seeing here
is
probably going to look pretty weird to
most people you know night h3
taking the double pawns it's like hey
andrea when you were learning chess
didn't they tell you don't put your
knight on the side of the board
yeah this semi looks weird to me i don't
know if this is a
an idea have you seen this before i'm on
i'm proud to say it happened okay so
maybe it isn't i was thinking like maybe
i don't play this opening maybe it's
you know a unique sideline but
so one of the one of the reasons that i
think she's playing it
is because i'm just going to take a
second and just go back because you
mentioned e6 for greg being sort of the
main idea
then i can see knight h3 being the move
and then the knight goes to f2
guard c4 guards g4 but the knight on h3
can't be taken when there's a knight on
d7 and pawn on e6 so
i think that alexandria had a plan going
into this position
she got surprised by knight v6 and she's
still trying to follow
her same plan but it doesn't work as
well against the move that greg had
i agree but you know hammer always says
respect your bishop so maybe it's not
bad because
black does sacrifice their bishop here
for that
absolutely no this is not a bad position
by any stretch i mean as you can see by
the eval bar
it it's hovering quite close to to equal
um i think that greg is probably happy
with his position
but um you know honestly compared to
compared to the last
time they had this where alexander
blendered her whole queen
yeah better exactly this is awesome
yeah sometimes the open jeep on the king
you can use it you can place your rook
on it bring your king to the corner and
use it as a way to attack your
opponent's king so
it's not always a weakness but it is a
little bit worse to play for white
and more uncomfortable yeah uh just just
a positional element that
hey if we get down to an end game it's
pretty easy to play for
for greg and greg right now launching
full pressure against this f4 pawn
but a bit of a counter-attacking move
here by alexandra hitting c7
hitting a7 and saying look if you play
c6 you're gonna lose your d-bomb
exactly and maybe coming to the d4
square later and e6 is also a weakness
yep yep and then a6 now he's saying look
you take my pawn where does your knight
go after he gets attacked
actually stuck behind enemy lines yep
knight c7 then i distract so maybe she's
gonna utilize that d4 square
yep and if knight d4 i think greg would
be very interested
in playing the move e5 uh hitting the f4
pawn
hitting the knight as well and if
alexandra takes that we get something
that alexandra wanted in the game where
she was black which is that beautiful
knight
sort of occupying the yeah square
yeah e5 is a pretty good rebuttal
so i would be interested in sort of
going back knight
to uh c3 and then after e5 trying to
play f5
yeah and he sees it yeah initially i
also like you
man we see we make the same mistakes
alex
we're like yeah knight d4 night in the
center and then
oh father's night coming to e5 and then
our bishop is gonna be under attack okay
and this is great andre it's really rare
that the audience gets to see
like you know you're here as a as a
simulation of what the photos might do
and then we have alexandra to you know
actually execute
the move there so that's a nice little
insight we have i mean i hope she's not
playing the same moves i'm getting
because i'm
lower rated than her so hopefully she
doesn't place every move i suggest
or maybe it's a good thing maybe it
means that i've made it up to her level
yeah and there's that move c5 uh which i
think is
is pretty much going to be a knockout
blow um in my opinion here i don't see
how alexandra saves a piece
knight and that um is necessary
defending the bishop
um alexander played b3 in the previous
position because
her pawn was being hit but just sort of
overlooking the
the need to play bishop to g2 so it's
these tactics
yep but i don't think she could have i
mean even if she would have defended her
bishop i mean
probably still would have been but who
knows she came back in the last game
from a losing position she could do it
again yeah and what's
what's uh funny is that although people
might not realize it
this game she's maybe down a full piece
but the advantage that
uh greg had last game might have been as
good as this or even
better he wasn't maybe up a full piece
but he had such a good position
and you're absolutely right she she came
back then although it feels harder to do
that when you're actually
down a full piece yeah i think the peace
advantage is going to be harder for greg
to
to throw and the time let's not forget
a factor yeah two-minute advantage here
um basically the last time she used the
time against greg greg got low on time
and
she used that to create some blunders
but with three minutes i don't think
greg is gonna be getting down to 20
seconds anytime soon
yeah especially it's very hard for her
to find a counter attack in this
position last time you know she had that
potential idea of doubling on the foul
the king but here her king is so exposed
she doesn't have much time to attack yep
and uh well speaking of an attack
there's a one move attack
you like to see it yep she's just trying
but unfortunately it can be easy easily
blocked
yeah and that rook is looking to access
the g-file
towards the king that knight is going
towards that e5 square
and even if alexander takes that pawn i
was going to say it's not the
end of the world for greg because
all he's looking to do is trade trade
trade when you're up material
just trade everything that's equal and
then what will be left well
your extra material so i think he's
looking to just simplify here
yeah i think that shows just how much of
like a weakness like the double pawns
and the the
exposed square in front of a king how
big of a difference it makes when you're
playing someone rated like 2700
that that positional advantage will make
all the difference in the end of the
game
absolutely yeah a small positional thing
not even down material just
just the way the position looks can
sometimes be the difference
yep king h1
uh was played i mean time is uh very low
for
alexander here just 35 seconds um she is
uh keeping the idea of hey bishop takes
h4 rook takes h4
and at least there's some queen h8
tricks there so the greg is doing his
last
double triple check he learned his
lesson
yeah so i think he's just uh spending
probably most of his time on this move
come up with a good one solve his
problems but um
yeah alexander is hoping for bishop
takes on h4
and greg comes up with queen e5 uh
trying to force a trade
yeah even with her check the kings can
easily escaped
escape and and black has much stronger
attack on the king
yep yeah i think i think trades are
all that greg needs to go for here um
something like bishop takes
now still met by rook takes h4 let's not
forget
um alexandra's king by the way is almost
getting checkmated as well
yeah so it's kind of a race here
the viking has the f7 escape square but
white's king doesn't have anywhere to
run
yep so i don't know one move if you're
really trying to trade everything
would be like bishop g5 as you can see
it just like hits
absolutely everything in the position um
if you really want to just go for some
trades you might lose another pawn but
you would at least uh get the pieces off
so we'll see
yeah and he can oh i was gonna ask why
do you think bishop p5 is better than
trading bishops right away
yeah just the rook takes h4 just not not
even dealing with those queen h8 mates
yeah i i feel like
it's not a huge threat but it's
definitely good to not give your
opponent any counter play
yep and there's a really nice move by by
greg
understanding that hey if bishop takes
although i just lost a piece
queen e4 yep check me
yep he removed the the rook that was
defending the pawn
and yep there you go that was a very
nice tactical play by greg
played very well this game yep and he's
he's opened up a a uh a third win here
so three wins in a row for greg
people might be wondering hey why is the
score you know 15 to three
i just got here alexandra is crushing
this guy uh the game
or the match rather did start with a 15
point handicap
which the players agreed on and as i've
mentioned before it was actually like
oh i think we should do a 12 point
handicap and greg was like
nah make it 15. 15 sounds good so that's
why the score is currently 15.
confident with this handicap and so far
he's proving his confidence correct but
still so many points to catch up for
greg
yeah and if you just joined you missed
uh the second game andrea we would agree
maybe that what that was the best chance
for for alexandra
um this match could easily be two to one
right now yep
all right all it takes is all it takes
is like you know one or two wins
uh in this uh in this five minute
portion to keep that
you know 15 point lead kind of uh
reasonable going into the bullet
exactly and then who knows maybe she'll
have some better chances in the bullet
and let's talk a little bit about this
uh this game we got here alexandra going
for the french which is an opening that
she's quite uh familiar with is this uh
again
something that maybe you could speak
about her uh her opinion
this is the one i refuse to memorize
because i'm not a fan
of the french she loves the french so
this was the one that i told the hammer
alex is going to study all on her own so
i don't know
well from what i noticed with her french
games is that her opening gets a little
bit messy
but maybe she maybe she did um review a
little bit of her french line so
yeah alex you're on your own
the french yeah if people uh you know
watch uh
alex and andrea's stream you'll probably
know already that alexander plays their
french all the time
the franchise to her like the london is
to me
perfect there you go everyone has their
opening that um you know
it might not be the the most popular or
maybe it is but it's dear to them and
they you know they won't
speaking of french positions it could be
worse that's the way i i like to talk
about the french
it's like you know whatever you got it
could be worse always remember that
so i think that's fine here i think your
position is actually pretty good
here yep this knight e7 move definitely
looks like something intentional she's
done
uh it would be more natural to have that
knight on f6 but then what would happen
with the open e file is that knight
would always be able to jump into
f5 yeah using the pin so that's a really
important detail
that she put the knight there covering
f5 and also blocking the e file so
um i like that from alexander knight on
e7 yeah i was gonna say the
position looks pretty comfortable for
black after she could castle
she has a strong dark diagonal her
development is pretty equal so it seems
pretty even to me
yep one thing that um has to be said
although i do like the move knight e7 is
that
when you castle kingside now there's no
knight on f6 to sort of save you
when things get messy all of a sudden
queen e4 makes a checkmate threat that
could be very hard
true that is true actually yeah queen e4
is
fantastic idea i didn't even think about
i guess
the only way to defend that would be
like a knight g6
move yeah knight g6 or some of those
ugly looking pawn moves that you're
never sure yeah
weaknesses yep and alexandra is
she's playing rook c8 she's playing
knight c4 so i'm a big fan of what she's
doing she's playing on
the side of the board where she sort of
has the space is a little bit stronger
over there
but one thing that i'm looking for is
when is she
going to feel confident castling because
at some point she's going to have to
castle and it's all about
to me how she handles the king side
pressure once she puts the king there
with no knight on f6
yeah i was going to say i think she she
was aware of the same idea you were
talking about
so she was delaying her castle as much
as she could trying to build up an
attack on the
queen side but it may be time eventually
she's gonna have to castle she can't
leave her kingdom
forever yeah you and your opponent kind
of look at each other and it's like well
are you going to castle yet you know
yeah exactly
i always have respect for them when
they're they're delaying their castle
yep so i guess one of the only other
things i would consider is the move e5
if you want to delay your castling
that's one of the ways to do it
one of the issues is right now if if you
start
collecting the knights and you know
alexander takes back you would drop that
e pawn
although you get the bishop pair you
would drop upon doing that and you're
not really advised to push pawns
in the middle of the board when your
king is still there so yeah and when the
queen and the
girl attacking on the same file it
doesn't look too safe
yeah so in that position in the position
we just saw and maybe in this one as
well i
really think that it's probably you know
a decent move to castle
but i agree but alexander just i can
tell that she's a little bit scared to
do that which is fair
and the longer she waits though the less
likely it is that she's gonna castle
yeah i i feel like she i it must be the
queen e4
threat that she's scared of but i don't
know it looks like black could pretty
easily defend with 96 and maybe try to
attack the queen on the e4 square but
she has a night maneuver plan bring your
knights in the center okay
yep and i think alexander might be
interested in
giving up the bishops here just
yesterday the queens
and then once the queens are treated
it's like all right sweet i can castle
exactly i'm curious if she'll go for the
end game
yeah the other the other options
remember if you want to try to like kick
that knight out with f6
i mean your king's still in the middle
you're running into queen h5 and
that's almost a knockout blow right
there so nice okay
i like that she went for the sun game
and as we saw from one
other game she can play pretty well in
these end game positions
yeah finally i think she's pretty happy
about that
yes i think this is a relief
so maybe knight c6 um so basically here
we have a position with
time even i think alexandra has done the
right thing definitely i would call this
a success for the opening knight c6
she's going for trades
uh i have to point out that with the two
bishops and the the
pawn majority which just means that
there's more pawns on the queen side for
white
on this half of the board i would prefer
greg's position and i think he's going
to be happy with it but
alexandra can't complain about what
she's got from the opening
yeah he does have the bishop for
advantage but her night on d5 is very
strong
so i'm just compensating for it
yep and i'm also going to say that rook
on e5
looking a little weird like it is that
bishop is blocking its way
yes for sure and now exactly now it
can't even return anywhere
cut off from the e file but white is
definitely eyeing that f3 square
and i was going to say speaking of f3
i don't know i don't think the pawn push
was a did you like the f3 pawn push
i i thought that's a square i i
definitely agree that
it looks weird i think it could have
been punished by alexandra because she
played really quickly she immediately
played rookie
and i think she might have missed an
opportunity there because f3 is a move
that you really want to play
it shuts that bishop down completely and
then i don't have six it takes away all
the squares it wants to go to so in
general it's a really really good move
but the in the position that greg played
it in his rook was still on this weird
square
and i feel like alexandra had a moment
just a brief moment there
to take advantage of it i don't think
she did so in the end i think f3 paid
off for greg
but yeah um it didn't have to it didn't
have to i think she had it
how could have black punished it so the
first thing that comes to mind if i'm
just going back here for a sec
is uh knight d7 uh just to again hit
that rook
yeah forcing it maybe to e3
yep forcing it to e3 which is another
weird square then maybe the knight jumps
into like c5
into b3 where it hits the a pawn it's a
sort of a long
yeah now the dark squared bishop can't
really go anywhere so that this makes
sense okay
i guess it still has the e1 plan but yep
so
that i think there was a moment there
where something could have happened but
let's get back to the game
time even a minute for a piece literally
dead even
and alexander's king is more active
she's finally going to kick that rook
out
it looks like and she does and uh again
i think
uh most people will find it a little
funny that greg's bishops developed and
then he said
uh actually put those right back where
they keep yeah exactly they're both
on the back ring and she's starting to
take up
older squares and they don't have the
dark square bishop doesn't have
many places to develop anymore yeah and
pro tip for anyone chat watching if you
ever want to
look like a grand master just put your
pieces back on the squares they started
if you ever put your pieces back on the
squares they started
during the game everyone's going to
assume that you know exactly what you're
doing
exactly that's really good because it
seems like such a beginner mistake but
no
it's just cause it's too high level for
us yeah do you have a lot to understand
yeah if anyone calls you out on it you
just tell them like ah it's just too
high
this is a grand master thing just can't
explain to you why it's good but it is
yeah exactly exactly so pro tip there
um rook d8 again alexandra is keeping
the time even
and keeping the position relatively even
but let's not forget those bishops are
just creeping around they're starting to
act
yeah they're finally trying to get out
of their shell i'm looking at the move
c4
um i think that you know
unless there's some crazy knight f4 like
tactical type of move
hitting both bishops or something if
that knight goes back to e7
then i think the bishop just goes to c3
or b4
and i'm really starting to like the way
those bishops are coming alive
yeah c4 is very strong it looks at first
like it it was a weak
move because you know the pawns are so
advanced they're not defended but i
agree after that bishop plan
oh look greg guy's gm he's doing it
again
every time that happens we just we can't
question it guys yeah
he he tends to play a little bit passive
when he has some really good
aggressive plans so i don't know if greg
is more of a passive player but
well check the time as well alexandra is
doing really really well
on the clock this is the part i was most
interested to see to see if she could
play in the end game
at um the 2700 level and hold the
position and so far i'm very impressed
and she is gonna have games where
unfortunately she just gets kind of
crushed
tactically that's gonna happen against a
strong player um
and we know it's going to happen but in
the games where she gets to these
positions
yeah end game stuff like this time even
she's got to capitalize these are her
chances
i agree maybe okay i was going to say
maybe bishop e6 looking for a trade
but she's just kind of dancing around
and i don't want this from her i don't
want her good strat
she just makes safe safe moves goes back
and forth just to keep her time
advantage
yep then that is totally fine totally
fine keep that d
file it looks like yep yeah
yep they certainly are okay and she
needs to play f5 or h5 here
has to be one of those two moves yep so
they don't lock her bishop back
okay she goes with f5 takes takes i
don't mind this for her
g6 and she may have an isolated pawn but
her bishop is defending everything so
the bishop's going to go to e2
and h5 wants to happen if she did h5
that wouldn't be the worst thing
bishop e5 oh oh this is bad news in my
opinion greg is really starting to
activate those bishops
c4
she's doing well on the clock
yeah i guess the bishop in the center
just cannot be attacked
because it doesn't necessarily do
anything but it's just gonna it's such a
strong square controlling
almost both of the biggest diagonals
move that pawn
play h4 h3 that's what i've done i don't
mind this from her though she's going
aggressive she's gone oh no oh
he has three seconds though everything
anything can happen here
yep that's totally true totally true
there's only plus one let's not forget
so trading rooks oh wow
it's funny alexandra's display picture
on chess.com
almost looks like yeah yeah
exactly i was going to say i thought
that was a live look at alexandra
i didn't even notice that yeah that's
how we started the match
man that was so close i never really
yeah i guess
that check kind of threw her off and
took her last second
andrea we are gonna go to our basically
our halftime break right here and
if there's someone who maybe needs a
half-time break refresh right now
i think it might be alexandra so she's
gonna go run down and give her a pep
talk
do that in fact do that i i think we
would i'd love to hear about that
afterwards so yeah we're not five
minutes i might go
dude dude you got this proud you're
getting these winning positions
yeah well she's still winning
technically in the points so yeah
exactly she's still waiting guys let's
not get 15
to four so we're gonna take a very short
break when we come back the rest of the
five plus one
portion be right back
all right and hello everybody welcome
back hopefully nobody went anywhere
that was a a break for us in the
commentary booth here for the players as
well so they got a little break
um and uh andre any any uh you know
behind the scenes insights into the
bowtie's house
yeah well alex came running up asking me
for one of my hats and
i think that's like greg's reaction i
think he liked alex's hat
she wanted to snap back but i said that
she should match greg's hat so let's see
if the hat brings the wins oh and an
energy drink
she's really um
oh and a blazer okay she wants to
win the the outfit award now i like it
very classy look
looks like a little british lady well
yeah i was gonna say she went from like
uh you know alexander botez chess player
to
alexander botez you know uh covert
spy yeah exactly
some sort of uh one of those type of
movies i like it though she's going for
a shift she says look
it did go that well before when it
changed everything the outfit the hat
energy drink i'm going uh way way
different
anything you can do to keep your
mentality positive and
looking up for the next rounds and uh
one thing that's important to note for
the audience
and for us to remember as well is that
the match clock
for the entire match was paused during
that break so it's not like it was any
advantage to either player
uh the the clock was paused and it will
simply resume
right now when the matches resume so no
time lost there in the break
all right and we're back
in d4 by alexandra that the the d4
is probably going to be seen you know
time and time again that's yeah
openings and she's also i don't know if
she did uh had any time for some chess
review
maybe uh talking to hammer on the side
there but we got this line again
yes oh i'm curious if well is this the
same line oh no it is yeah
i'm guessing he's going to go again with
the knight b6 he probably is because
it's been working
for him yeah i think normally when
you're having these type of um
we call them theoretical discussions
with your opponent i think what you
normally do
is if it's working for you you just
close your eyes keep doing the exact
same thing and say hey
look you got to do the work here it's
fine for me i'll do this all day
yeah well and on white side hopefully
she's learning from her mistakes like
that that knight h3 move that
wasn't good she can try different
different plans okay speaking of a
different plan
uh this one does look different she
tried e5
um there was a knight h3 try and now
she's going for queen d2
so we'll see if this uh pays off here
but i think she's really
conscious that the knight on f3 allows
the move knight g4
i don't think she likes that which is
why she's not putting a knight on h3 so
i think this knight b6 move by greg
totally throwing off alexandra
and as we can see here opening trouble
already
yeah this is a very aggressive move
which gets rid of the knight g4 threat
but
uh interesting we're gonna have to give
the
alexandra's b3 was there no way to save
it
well at this point i think because the
pawns being attacked
like you almost have to play bishop
takes knight on b6 which is an
ugly move um that would save it but it's
not a move that you're really supposed
to play in these openings which is why
alexandra didn't do it
um but she's she's not solving the
the knight b6 move by greg and i think
that
is highly effective for him yeah
yeah she needs to find an idea but you
know there's luckily with the speeches
we have so many games she'll have plenty
of tries and hopefully
i have time we get down to the quicker
matches we'll figure out a good line as
white
and that the the worry is that when you
get to shorter time controls
it's even worse yeah position like you
know because it compounds
how bad it is so what alexandra needs to
do and it's very difficult
for anyone but for chess players it's
difficult to adjust on the fly
she has to basically the next time she
gets the white pieces she can't repeat
this
she has to somehow think in her head
what went wrong and what can i do
that that would fix that and she has to
do that while she's thinking about all
the other games she's playing
not easy to do exactly yeah that's the
whole point of
why we're preparing our opening so much
so so that she doesn't waste time in the
opening
because obviously giving um greg a time
and advantage is gonna be even more
of a blow yep and what we see here greg
is just taking a pawn he's saying look
queen trades fantastic winning pawns
fantastic he's just looking to trade
down here he knows he has the advantage
early on i think he's gonna snap the
queens off yep and take that knight back
yep he's using his material advantage
but
i mean yes he has a weak isolated pawn
could maybe
get a little bit of material back yeah
alexandra is going to have to i was
going to say show off the bishops and
andrea i mean what's going on here
where's the bishop c1
and looking like a grand master that's
why that move
i think your bishops are pretty active
and this position i don't think that
but i know hammer hammer would be happy
with your bishop there we may be down
some material but at least
you know our bishops are very active
yeah oh they're active all right there's
well the the good thing for alexandra is
she's lost all her pawns
so there's lots of space for those
fishes to be active
exactly let's look at it that way um
yeah looking looking like this should be
as i mentioned alexandra is going to
have games where
unfortunately she gets into trouble uh
gets beat tactically
uh greg is a stronger player he's gonna
have a few games where uh
let's say it alexander is gonna get
crushed a few games but that's okay
that's part of the match
she has that handicap for a reason and
she needs to capitalize on the other
opportunities that she gets it's crazy
that he's finding all these tactics
straight in the opening
which we were preparing the opening
exactly to avoid
that issue but he's finding these
tactics in the
positions we didn't study so yeah and i
think and i think it's very safe
another one this is almost resignable
yeah
three and a half and she is going to
resign i i totally agree with that
it's a full extra piece just get to that
next game no point in dragging that one
on back to the french that was i think
her best opening i agree it went well
with her
it went well for her the other game and
going into strong end game so
so i would say that she just needs to
repeat
what she did last time she uh was doing
well on the clock doing well in the
position
there's no reason to change what she did
uh greg is repeating his position
uh when alexandra is white so i think
she's yes that's what i was gonna say
yeah greg has his repetition for white
let's see if greg which how he will
change his response to her french
yeah i wonder if if he is because if
there's one thing i know about
you know ims gm's when they get those
positions with the two bishops
they feel like they're supposed to be
better so he might actually repeat it as
well
go right back into it just it's kind of
like that stubborn
you know strong player tendency like oh
i have to be better you know
let me prove it again i mean he didn't
he wasn't getting in a bad position in
one equal position so i guess there's
no need for him to change it necessarily
yeah and
and uh you know if both players are
happy getting back to the same position
we might see that but already something
completely different i think was it
actually alex that was knight c6 played
last time
uh this really i can't remember yeah
cause i i know she went with that knight
a5 plan but i don't remember if
white was able to trade yeah i almost i
don't know the french
yeah she definitely did okay yeah she
waited to move that night much later in
the game
interesting interesting so maybe that
did happen last time and greg didn't
trade
can't remember at the moment but uh all
that needs to be said is that the
current position
is different than last time it's totally
different the trade has put the queen on
c6
normally what black ends up doing is at
some point going for like b5 bishop b7
uh putting that bishop on the long
diagonal and saying hey that knight
can't move or you're gonna get mated on
g2
so do you think the trade is favoring
black now in this game
yeah i think uh i think in this line
where the queen goes back to d7 in this
french and you go b5 bishop b7
it's nice to have the queen on c6
because i agree you know even if the
knight goes to d4 to hit it once that
bishop gets to b7 that's no longer an
option
so um again though with h6 i think what
alexandra is doing now
and maybe a little bit concerned for her
is i feel like she's kind of combining
her ideas from the last position into
this position and
they don't they don't transfer that
easily
yeah exactly i think she needed to go
straight for that developing plan
h3h6 wasn't necessary
yeah um because without a knight on d4
there isn't as much of a risk of knight
f5
and what i think is going to happen here
and i was about to say it is just like i
was gonna say
yeah that that trade looked too juicy to
do that to the pond oh and there's the
pin okay
yeah oh not another tactic man
puzzle rush instead uh so that's the is
that the botes flaw for this match
to too much opening theory not enough
tactics
i yesterday when we're training i was
like i also thought we were spending too
much time on the opening but
because alex and i you know we play way
more games and we do like real training
on stream and puzzles
so we definitely need to work on our
puzzles yep and and shout out to
chess.com they have a puzzle week coming
up because
that would be perfect that would be
perfect
no the chess.com puzzles are great
they're very fun to practice so
yeah well tell that to alexandra yeah
that's true i think this one honestly is
uh resignable yeah just like the last
one this is a full rook
and it's going to be a full rook plus
the bishop is going to escape after you
don't even get the bishop
for the rook yeah it seems like she's
walking into these tactics with
a move like h6 instead of going straight
for the development plan
i'm trying to find like how she keeps
walking into these opening puzzles what
is the common
factor um so one thing that i could
maybe point out which i have mentioned
in the other line is
i feel like greg is doing uh he's doing
a kind of tricky
job of playing a move that maybe isn't
the best
but it just gets alex that little bit
out of her
preparation and what she might be
familiar with and then what what alex
does
is she plays the way that she intended
to play initially
against the the new move that greg does
it doesn't work the same way
and greg is really taking advantage of
that that's what it looks like to me
yeah that makes sense because that
knight takes c6 move was definitely
favoring black but
clearly that was the whole reason we
fell into this pin so
yeah yep and greg immediately went b3
bishop b2 in this game
why do i mention that because that
bishop hits that g7 pawn
and that's exactly what alexandra's
knight e7 move doesn't cover
so it feels like he's he sees what moves
she's trying to do what what different
ways she's trying to play
um and he's yeah he's covering it
exactly the way the way it should be i'm
very curious how
should she have defended the g7 square
because her move knight f6
seemed i don't think that if six was the
mistake was it
no probably not forced it's probably
just b5 that gave the game
yeah yeah but also it's the order in
which you do things remember if she had
done
um if she had done b5 before maybe
bishop d5 would be possible
it worked true that would have helped
and let's also remember h6 if the
bishop's going to b2
a move like h6 probably not necessary at
all you don't even need to play h6 so
maybe you get that knight to f6
first no h6 then you have time for b5
and it's just that game of chess is
often determined by just those few tempi
in the opening
exactly especially at this level it's
just one move in the opening that
doesn't
necessarily push back your opponent's
bishop or develop the knight before
the pawn and they'll make all the
difference yep and knight h4
just again looking to solve problems
tactically here alexandra's king is in
the middle of the board
and she cannot really take this this
bishop on b7
um i like the fact that she's playing
one of these games out
i don't think she should just resign all
of them immediately
um at least make greg prove it a little
bit but with the amount of time he has
and the rating that he has i think he's
got it yeah
it's probably resignable soon
just because i have faith that greg with
this material advantage
i think that uh basically she's playing
on because that bishop's on
b7 and yeah look it once he saves it you
know i'll resign then he's up a full
rook but
i have like you know just a little bit
of a few more tries
yeah exactly let's see i mean okay the
bishop's hanging here so that's
yeah just take that and i think she
might resign here
once she realizes that you know one more
check one more check one
and knight takes f5 here is going to be
lights out after king eight
yep all right
oh no i guess the rook hanging is also
there oh no she threw that she's getting
rid of the
figure she's throwing
that's actually op she's tying her hair
up greg can't copy
that's how you know it's getting serious
she always says she thinks better when
she puts on her ponytail
and greg can't match that so maybe we
just know that
this is dangerous yep andrea this is
dangerous i think alexandra
just took the opportunity no response
she finally took him out of the books
okay well that is the first time we've
actually seen alexandra
uh come up with you know uh some opening
moves maybe off the board that greg
couldn't handle
oh i'm excited for this so this is a
line that hammer prepared
and he's walking into it perfectly so
this is a line we and
we're originally not gonna go for this
because it gets us into a really weird
position
so i also have to think what was the
line here i believe
we we take and now we play queen f3 we
have prepared
i'm really excited and then takes him
takes to a position where
black could force a draw and if they
don't it should be giving white slide
advantage and greg being the stronger
player he wouldn't want to force the
draw
so exciting and alexandra playing e4
wow that's uh i've always known her as a
d4 player so if she's playing e4
better believe that she is trying to
play against something very specific
she's taking her time here but i know i
know for a fact we prepared queen f3
oh wait no no
no alex we prepared this together
how did you forget this one even i
remembered this one
oh no this is this is where you gotta
this is like
wwe wrestling you gotta you gotta tag
you in for that move queen f3 and then
let her play the rest
we'll never forgive the he found the
most beautiful line he was so proud
because
it was greg's pet lion and greg would
play the same response
every time and we forget queen f3
i'm very upset i i don't
know any anyone watching just don't show
this to hammer just make sure you never
say
oh this didn't happen camera's currently
doing a commentary but he said that
after he finishes he's going to go look
and uh alex you better remember and this
was the first
line he taught us and now alexandra is
probably like
uh you know i don't think this is now
she doesn't know how to play it and i
i think black's already winning oh man
that queen of three
boobs i'm so upset yeah i know
especially when she's not she never
plays these positions so
it almost looks like after an a5 i don't
know if this is a thing but
queen d4 and then if knight c6 you play
queen takes bishop
and if bishop c6 i think this knight
actually just
gets trapped like it's so weird but
there's no place to put it
yeah black definitely has a big
advantage here
and he's played exactly that which is
not a good sign
and we don't we did but that was another
thing like if greg deviates
if we deviate then it's not going to end
well for us
because we never play this and greg does
uh andre i think this is maybe the third
game in a row now where
uh honestly alexandra's kind of been
lost in about 10 moves it's not
it's just the opening which is it's so
rough and it's definitely hard for your
mentality because it's not like
she's too weak of a player he knows
these lines so well and he sees these
tactics but
when she gets into equal positions we've
seen that she has a really
great chances so you just have to
remember hammer's lines alex
oh man this this is where uh it's so
difficult because
if if she could just check that line for
like two seconds
in between the games it would be so
helpful but you cannot do that you can
only do that during the breaks
yes of course yeah that's why i like
when i be preparing my tournaments like
right before rounds
you finish your game you have like 30
minutes before you you do a quick recap
and that can save you so much energy
during the game
yep and honestly what we're about to see
here alexandra is going to
lose this night and literally she will
have
no peace development yeah it's it's
pretty
much over from here i think
maybe bishop there is an option but
unnecessary i think he's just gonna take
that back
maybe she did need me after all
castles and now i think
well bishop bishop to g4 is definitely
an option
uh it might look funny here that greg
basically has his entire queenside pawns
wiped out
by alexandra's night just hopping around
taking everything
it is a piece down it is a piece down
yeah and i think i think at this point
um you know hey if alexandra gets all of
these pawns
sort of up the board she definitely has
chances but she's so
far away from that at the moment i mean
yeah if those phones were advanced they
would be killer all past
pawns you know maybe she can pull
something off
yeah hang on andrea let's let's you
never know more connected past pawns
hello
i know those are stronger than maybe
even two rooks
yep they can definitely be uh stronger
than a lot of pieces but generally what
where they have to be
is closer to your opponent's side of the
board yeah they haven't made a lot of
progress but you know one day
one day they'll get there yeah alexander
just needs about 10 moves for free and
then we might have a game here
rookie 8 played and there we go all
right we got one of them up there
they're coming
yeah the troops are are marching in yeah
and look how scared he is
he's doing he's doing those gm things
where he puts his pieces on the back row
yeah i actually i lost him i hope
because i was so deceived by the eval
bar
which for a computer like it looks like
a huge advantage for white but
i don't know i don't think it's as over
as i thought it was
i think what's the issue is again queen
c7 it's like almost impossible to me
wow queen c7 g3
loses the h3 pawn and it's actually kind
of the same
position if you remember when alexandra
was playing the french i was talking
about queen e4
it's kind of the same problem it's so
hard to defend that sometimes
yeah wow and well i guess
what could she even try
unfortunately i'm kind of out of ideas
here she almost has to play something
like f4 like
kind of yucky move but if she pushed
h4 and then queen c7 and then g3
wouldn't that save the i mean the bishop
would still come to h3 but
then rookie one you don't lose that pawn
that's true what i'm concerned about in
that position is bishop g4 to
f3 and then like queen into h3 and meet
on those weak light squares but
oh no but it wasn't good so this wasn't
a good sign
yeah sometimes you're happy to see the
coffee moves sometimes it's uh yeah
i mean anything was losing but what you
know
greg didn't play did you guys play the
you you said bishop g4 right
he did e3 he he wants to end this game a
lot quicker
he alexandre literally has no pieces
developed yeah she can't even
take greg is looking for a ko here yeah
bishop can't take and then rug
takes it oh okay well there we're going
to get fourth but you know
alexander is going to lose this game
with not a single piece leaving the back
rank
yeah it's pretty crazy because like the
position without that mate threat
would have been totally playable for
white but this one attack that was so
unstoppable
was the whole was the whole win well i
think she's doing
i think she's collecting pawns at this
point yeah
yeah if queen takes bishop by the way
there would have been rook check and
she would have lost her bishop and this
is looking pretty over
if i was greg i would try to style on
her and play queen takes f4
queen takes f4 wow pawn takes bishop
takes
and then there's a rookie one made idea
so i i would look to style here
you know it's not that great but as you
can see the eval bar black's still
winning after sacking
the whole queen on f4 yeah i i think
greg needs to give you
some um fashion points you can put on
some hats and you need to give them some
style points in the game
perfect i'll take it a nice trailer that
is
that was brutal but it was just that
queen of
queen ups3 line that we missed
and uh andrea what's happening here as
greg
has now won seven in a row is we have to
start talking about a few things
number one is that after we need seven
games we realize
he might win almost the most games that
have ever been won in the five plus one
portion because the games are so quick
that's the problem is that she's losing
them so quickly
um that he's actually able to get more
and more games
in so he's scoring a lot of points and
the other thing we have to talk about
is she's dangerously close to losing 10
games in a row
yeah but you know maybe we are also
approaching the other time
formats and the but the issue is if we
don't solve our opening issues
then alex doesn't have any advantage in
the shorter time formats
yeah it's like you know any any alex
supporters coaches out there if you're
listening
she needs a good pep talk after this uh
five plus one portion
about a few of those openings because
it's just the openings but
yeah once she gets past the openings
we've seen time and time again she's had
fantastic games where she actually is
really good in time scrambles
a lot better in the end game portion and
greg is kind of as you pointed out a
little bit passive
uh decisive but he hasn't
been forced to play any of those
positions because he's winning the games
because he's getting these so killing
tactics in the beginning but
you know he only has like half of her
points so
still out of hope yep and uh
let's let's be clear alexandra in this
position it might not have been so great
last time but
this was her game where she actually
could have won yeah
the the issue with the moroxy bind also
she never plays
the sicilian this was my opening and i
had memorized these lines because i love
playing against the roxy bind but
uh we're messing up some of the ideas
here and we should be punishing his
queenside castle
because it's incorrect but instead he's
getting the attack on our king so
yeah and king's or queenside castle
rather
screams to me like it's one of those
moves uh
that it might not be the best but again
it's not an alexandra's
uh yeah opening theory and it's just
taking her out of book just enough
i mean she's trying she's she's
sacrificing something trying to
maybe open up nearest king yeah you
can't you can't lose
pawns if you sacrifice them first yep
exactly
you know last game she had too many
funds and now we're sacrificing them she
has to find the balance
exactly somewhere in the middle we'll
get there we'll get there just gotta
keep experimenting
yep yep okay so a4 a3 and this has been
seen before by greg
he pretty much always stops uh the a
pawn with a3 and he's gonna eventually
like
shuffle his king over to b1 maybe even
right now uh
knight d5 looks very strong to me oh no
yeah this also looks strong he's going
for the attack usually the idea after
knight takes h5
hey we all might be tempted by these
rook sacks but another idea is to get
that queen out to h6
and go for g4 um yeah
open the h file that's why typically i
always try to push h5
and because if you allow whitetail open
up exactly once they bring their queen
it's so hard to defend and
all right now i think that queen age six
that i don't even know how but could
defend
yeah i think greg was like look queen h6
after i take with check king f7 i don't
really have a checkmate
right off the bat and he wanted to get
his king away from some potential pins
make sure so he's saying look i have
that for next move now it's your turn
again because it's unstoppable so
good to stop while your opponent's
counter play first
yep that's a definitely a very very
mature decision there
knight d5 is also now possible again
because he shuffled the king over
so that would threaten 97 and the queen
and the queen would uh for white would
also come into h6 as we talked about so
this is looking pretty good for for greg
and
i know there's plus one seconds but you
look at the time he's only used like 30
seconds
wow yeah he's just killing it straight
from opening but you have to say
while he was playing a little bit he's a
little bit more of a passive player
that shows off as one of his strengths
because for me i probably would have
just been
really distracted by the queen of six
went to the attack but his preventive
moves are a very good skill
yeah and and at some points as you
pointed out maybe in the end game later
on
you know he needs to be more decisive
but the fact that he's playing
these defensive moves even when he's in
an attacking position it works really
well
exactly he learned his lesson where she
gave he rate gave alex one attack in one
of the first few games and never did it
again
yep 100 and hey rook c3 might not be
the winning move the best move but i i
kind of like it she's trying something
you know when all lost is all hope is
lost you got to try to create some
issues
yup i do not hate this at all um after
let's say king b2 has an idea
to defend the pawns the rook might go to
b8 for another sack on b5
and after queen takes uh h7 king f7
i don't know you know we're running away
yeah
it'll be it'll take him a little bit of
time to look for a defense
yeah so one one i guess attacking idea
after queen h7 king f7
might be rook h6 to keep in mind hitting
that g6 pawn
and you know maybe five but just that
that is probably how white is going to
look to proceed
yeah so white's attack is too forcing
and it doesn't give black
time to bring the rook to g5 and
yeah but as as with attacks hey the
computer might be like
uh hey craig don't worry it's plus four
yeah good question but
at the same time a human looks at this
and says yeah it's intimidating
and look at that oh and he's playing
that there we go like we said that
passive play
he sometimes it's good but sometimes
it's blocking his
sight from seeing the winning forcing
attack
yeah absolutely i mean alexandra gets
maybe the rook over
this bishop can slide into b3 and as
soon as this
knight really joins the game like knight
e6 knight f4 knight c5
and once that knight gets in there i
think there's real chances for alexandra
but she has to play a little bit quicker
right now and activate all the pieces
yes exactly and it is giving a little
bit of hope that he's he's getting
scared he's getting defensive
but the time like you mentioned two
minutes already
yep um i think rook v8 is very
reasonable
rook d4 and what is he planning here
something that i think
is really annoying he's maybe planning
to take that pawn
but maybe more importantly he's gonna
stick that real quick
guard the pawn and be like look yeah
that everything's protected now what are
you gonna do
yup he found a good defense of course
you know he sacrificed a bit of the
attack but now there's no chances for
black
to enter the king yeah and and we might
say hey
greg should have played a more
aggressive move than that but if he's
gonna play passive the problem is
he's really good at it he's a really
good defender
and alex's strength is definitely like
finding a comeback and he's losing
positions and he
just never allows it
[Music]
i think rook b4 is the way to go here
yep
look before and there's no more attacks
on his pawns
yeah she can take that but she would be
walking directly into a pin
herself um either c4 or queen b2 would
take care of the threat there
now i think there's still hope basically
if alex can get her knight
to c5 that'd be fantastic unfortunately
now knight e6 is met by bishop c4
and queen g2 would be a protest gambit
let's not play that
yeah it's hard here because in time
pressure when so many natural
moves are losing and you have to waste
time calculating here
there's just it's so much pressure to
keep up with 17 seconds
yeah yeah and the other thing is that
greg knows
that she has low time so he's going to
play like kind of tricky moves
he's going to use that against her he's
definitely putting the pressure on
okay c4 at this point the knight to me
just needs to move the knight needs to
like
i like that yeah i don't know i mean he
does have a pass pawn but putting all
his pawns on the square of his bishop
kind of locked it in and
now she can finally develop her own
bishop
i kind of like i i like the plan she's
making for developing her pieces still
still winning for white but it's
improving yep completely agree
the knight is finding uh a path to a
good square here
c5 d4 f4 depending on
what she wants to do but i think that's
great
yeah there we go you can see the
computer starting to understand like
white's got a great position but hey
black's position is kind of improving a
bit
yes but the issue is i think those two
past pawns are just
might be unstoppable yep alexander's
doing a good job getting the king off
that diagonal you never know when
there's going to be a chat king on a
dark square nice and safe
he's trying to go into the end game
makes sense but those four sets
material
nervous here the time 4.3 remember you
don't get like plus
10 seconds every move you get plus one
one which is
hardly anything it takes most people one
second to process the move or think of
the next one
yeah honestly that the time is the
biggest exciting factor and
i'm almost flagged there yeah
yeah she almost has to be in like
pre-moved territory exactly
oh my gosh wow yeah it's crazy because
like once you get down to two seconds
you're never
going up you're never gonna get to like
a equal 4 second every round
so some kind of quicker tactics there um
i like the speed from alexandra i can't
say i'm a fan of the moves but
she you know she just doesn't want a
flag but
it's lost yeah
all right here we go and i think we'll
get well you know let's
let's hope for alexandra's sake she
doesn't lose the game in 10 moves
but i think this is gonna be the last
game in a five plus
one time control i don't know whether to
be excited or worried about the other
time controls
but maybe the fact that greg will have
less time even though he'll have better
opening positions maybe her speed will
give an advantage
and he won't see him killing lines i
absolutely agree
with that both ways yeah the lower the
time the better for alexander and look
for the first time
she finally admits the london she admits
that
her younger sister has the better
opening
yes i i dude if i was there i'm telling
you
um but it's okay i i always get very
picky when i watch your london because
london is the only player only opening
actually has white which you know i'm
gonna branch out
soon but i i've studied a lot of those
lines i'm a big fan of london
so how's she doing right now um so
well the knight normally doesn't come to
d2 especially pushing c4 knight c3 is
better
but hammer did discuss that he doesn't
like the doubled c
pawn so i also i respect your decision
so pretty solid so far maybe not my my
line but i think it's
so far so good well if it's not your
line then
it must be garbage yeah exactly
uh knight d7 so black wants to play e5
generally in these positions
i am not a fan of playing bishop on d3
because i never liked the
the idea that could end up on e4 so i
would go for like bishop e2
and bishop h2 yes that is my line as
well
yeah and i agree knight c3 might be sort
of a little more
following my instincts but knight d2 the
way it happened trey
queen's out can't complain about that
it's more that alexandra needs to be
familiar with bishop ii bishop h2 ideas
and she's got
yeah my only worry about the queen on d2
is that if he gets
e4 the knight doesn't have the d2 square
but now he'll have
he'll have the d4 square so right um
now in the london just as a general
thing uh there's not many positions
where i get attacked on f4 and i go
forwards to g5 yeah
it's definitely not theory but i think
for players like greg probably doesn't
have all his lines against london
memorized so it might benefit her
yep i think at this point the bishop is
not going to get trapped it can
always you know go back here so no
worries about that i think castling is
pretty important for
white to do and just as a general thing
couple moves ago i'm not a big fan of
taking on e5 i think yeah yeah comes
back with the bishop
that you know she can keep her center
pawns and be happy about that but
uh position is not bad here uh i think
she just needs to play a little bit
faster
have more confidence in this london yeah
i wasn't a fan of it either but i would
say maybe it was good because then
because her knight doesn't have the d2
square at least trading would mean that
her knight could go forward once they
push e4
and now she's got 34 push so just
getting into an interesting position
so she might want to go with bishop h6
to trade pieces off it's kind of a lot
different
than a london now it basically feels
like a king's indian yeah
this bishop also might want to go back
to e3
and first off greg says look you just
played e4
your pieces don't look like they can do
a good job defending it right now
how do you handle a simple one move
attack
with a simple one move defense makes
sense yep
this looks good i like that a bishop is
controlling the d8 square so she can
bring her rook to the file but
and normally the f6 move i normally
don't
mind it because it you know it blocks
his bishop it opens up the light square
diagonal
so i wish i won g5 i was doing a good
job
yep yep and it probably should come back
to
e3 it hits the knight from that square
so if it ever gets attacked i think
that's where it should go
um i'm wondering if greg is thinking
about something very aggressive sort of
in the f5
realm but it looks like no he's he's
going positional
f5 is always very difficult to play i
wonder if well you could still go for it
eventually yep queen on c6
um basically greg is playing on the dark
squares here and wow
kind of combining all the ideas that we
mentioned
f5 is pretty strong so
f4 is the one you don't want to overlook
that is
a free bishop so careful about that
and if you take on f5 um first of all i
don't think you can grab this pawn on g2
because there is bishop f3 but she is
going to go f3 to get
bishops did you think f3 is better than
trading on f5 and
pawn takes back on f5 well yeah the
thing about
taking on f5 is that it doesn't solve
your problem you're still
facing um f4 uh true
so if you're going to play pawn takes f5
you better have the next move ready so i
don't mind this for alexandra i don't
yeah i
at first i was skeptical but then i
didn't realize yeah the f4 thread is
unstoppable so mine is well blocked
yep yeah knight b3 so she's covering
this i think
i was gonna say he's gonna play a5 and
look to kick that knight away
question time for alexandra is she gonna
play a4 and she does i
think that she gives up a lot of squares
but i like the move yep
what did she have to play there i'll
just point it out because i think it was
kind of important
instead of castling after bish buffet i
think she would have punished greg
if she had maybe played c5 herself yeah
i think she she played so quickly there
because you know she saw bishop before
giving a check she didn't want to waste
time but
you know this is a very interesting move
it's harder to find it's not as
intuitional
so this this position i'll just say
is so rough for white
just because of the fact that we're sort
of headed towards an end game
and there's going to be the two
remaining bishops are going to be these
ones
yep and the bomb and guys in chat
can we get a count on how many light
square pawns alexandra has because yeah
it's going to be rough in an end game i
think greg is
up on time he's got a great positional
edge and i think
from what you and i have seen from
greg's play so far he would love
this kind of game yeah and you know he
doesn't have to take it now but the
issue is the bishop's pin
so it's bound to happen yeah and to some
people
this type of advantage for black is like
almost better than like a free pawn
uh just just having that dark square
control
everywhere um and if the pieces just
trade on the d file
the bishops trade if everything trade
trade trade for trade it's going to be
even material
but alexander is going to be pretty far
behind
probably more than than you might think
yeah i wonder if she could try like king
f1 hope
hope he doesn't take the bishop and then
maybe put that guy somewhere but i don't
think there's any way to avoid oh maybe
greg heard you
yeah no i don't think greg would miss
the
the bishop trade yep um i think he
think he's gonna oh that is a
okay i think that's a weird move you
didn't like his pawn takes
i mean it connects it brings like you
know a backwards pawn but it does
connect his
pawns then again the e5 pawn is in
weakness so i don't know if he needs the
defense
yeah so i think that alexander can try
to set something up where like
the rook goes on d3 kind of guards her
weak pawn and she puts her queen
behind it like nice and then she's
hitting a5 she's hitting d6
uh she can put her bishop on d1 to guard
that
uh pawn on b3 i don't think it's the end
of the world for
alexandria i think she needs and she's
done exactly that
big fan of what she just did yeah pretty
solid fortress here
i don't really know how black can enter
breakthrough
maybe yeah maybe h5 g4 but oh
so an easy thing to underestimate is
that uh trading the queens is not
actually a good thing for you
um as white because now black probably
uh you know over time will be able to
get that king to c5
to b4 and if the queens are on the board
that can cannot take those kind of
journeys that makes sense
that's a very good point see i'm
actually i always like this commentary
because i learned a few things as well
my mind games are my weakest parts so
that's a great endgame lesson because i
never really know when you want to trade
the queens and positions like this
yeah and it's kind of tough because you
feel like hey black has the upper hand
and he does yeah you want to trade the
queens to get rid of the pressure
yeah exactly the queen for white was
probably the only thing keeping her
really
in the game there wow so this is a
position where greg is basically gonna
waltz his king sort of around to lisa
yep
he's doing exactly that and he's going
to play h5
and g4 and alexandra is going to
she could watch him as well maybe
like over to the queen side yeah what do
you think about that she's doing it
yep so what's going to happen here is uh
she's going to be successful in getting
over there but
after black plays h5 brings the rook
over to 88 and plays g4
black's going to be infiltrating i see
yeah if she could have maybe defended
the file so that
he couldn't come to the second rank but
yeah her
rook is dropped in by that bishop yep
and he's he's got the g5 he's gonna play
g4
once he gets g4 he's either gonna go
like g3 or pawn takes and he's to
infiltrate and he's going to be first
and being first is all that matters just
one move behind
for her i know it's it's painful because
the pawns are even here the pieces are
even it's like hey
i should be like losing this it's crazy
it's like almost exact
dead equal position but just one move
behind will make all the difference
yep um so i think a little bit of a
strange move greg played rook g7 instead
of just playing
yeah he seemed to waste the tempo yeah
i don't think that was necessary very
important
yeah i don't think that was necessary um
still
he's probably comfortable happy here um
but
alexander can't complain she's got a
rook down there as well yeah and i like
your bishop there a lot seems to be now
defending and the rook can't enter
anymore
especially now that she has the file yep
absolutely um and hey if greg like puts
his bishop somewhere like and it gets
traded
it's actually checkmate on c8 so you
gotta be super careful
it's starting to look like a draw to me
i'm not sure if greg can break it
anymore
yeah probably what um he's hoping to do
is get the bishop to g4 so in this
position if greg moves his bishop
alexander is going to have to move i
don't think she wants them oh
and she's going to be in sioux wrong
soon because she's going to have to move
a rook which is going to allow bishop g4
yep and what she has to do is whenever
this is a move or threatened
she has to be threatening check me
somewhere on this king
yeah and if she delays and moves her
king back then he would be able to come
to before but
okay he's alexander is doing a good job
so if
if the king starts to move back i would
instinctively move my king towards the
king side
interesting yeah and then the only way i
have the king side is
because couldn't black try to come king
c5 king b4
yeah so basically as many squares as
black is away from c5 i would be that
many squares away from c3
okay ah that makes sense and what just
happened there
greg just did a sort of a classic trick
where
uh he just shuffled he just shuffled the
piece he's gonna win this game now he
got the tempo
and that was not losing for alexandra
but
he he just waited around and
unfortunately she did make that mistake
in time pressure
um yeah this is completely lost here
it's so hard because
she could have held the draw but it's
just those her last seconds
is under 10 seconds he had a minute yep
it's not easy
i'm just gonna go i think the position's
weird i'm just gonna go back to that
yeah
after king c6 it's like what should she
do just move her king she had the rook
covering g4
king back king d2 king anywhere really
she's covering it i'm gonna get back to
the game just to
watch the end here but that's exactly
the moment where
greg didn't have a threat but it's like
she thought he had a threat so she made
a different move
so the rook should have only came to the
back rank when you played king c5 when
it would only actually have a mate
threat right
you've got it oh you've got it a nice
little end game lesson
that's so rough because she was so close
like
so close came back from a disadvantaged
position and
almost had that draw yeah and you saw
the look
that you kind of the handshake that that
greg gave there at the end
he knows that he probably knew that that
wasn't totally winning
and he didn't have a way to win it but
he was just kind of going in
the grand master shuffle the grand
master shuffle uh
well we'll call it that i like the name
the grand master shuffle well this is
that i'm
not a gm tournament so uh greg is
already you know if he's playing like a
gm he's he's over performing
for sure i always call him a gm because
we were talking about those gm moves
with the bishops and he plays like one
so you know
exactly exactly so alexandra is
uh uh started with 15 points greg won
nine games in a row
uh there is not gonna be ten games in a
row in five minutes so
hey no no adoption and five minute
portion we can we can say that that's
the goal here we go no i'm excited for
the next few games i predict alex is
gonna have a nice comeback
yeah and uh the next portion is gonna be
three plus one so that's why we think
you know alexander has been doing well
in these time scrambles
uh that when the game goes longer she
does a lot better you know she's gotta
get out of those opening troubles the
break is gonna be good for
you know the chat to get their snacks
refreshed for you and i to take a short
break and for the players especially
to refresh before coming back so andrea
we're going to take a short break here
and when we come back we're going to
continue with alexander botez against
greg shahadi in the i'm
not a gm tournament after this
and welcome back guys you will uh
only hear my voice for now but just
wanted to
uh introduce you guys to and remind
everyone of
the arena kings season six which is uh
getting started monday january 11th
so uh 20 000 prize fund for that i think
that is one of the
kind of most well-known events uh andrea
on
chess.com and we get another season of
that um
has uh has alex been been competing in
those uh you
at all i think i did playing arena kings
i remember like
uh two years ago alex i'm not sure you'd
have to ask her
but i know these are always a lot of fun
to watch these are also my favorite
yeah it's like a full season competing
for prizes starts monday january 11th
and
pretty much all your favorite streamers
should be or will be competing
so just a reminder about that i know
that's also a reminder for me to pencil
that in the calendar
all right and i see we're back here we
got the cams what is greg
he actually does do crossfit i remember
i learned that about him when we first
played our match
he almost looks like uh he's just pacing
in his office he looks concerned
i don't know you know they sure have
been
working out before these rounds keeping
themselves energized
alex needs to pull back her dumbbell
yeah what happened like she started the
match full of energy
lifting weights then she changed outfits
drinking energy drinks like
what's the game plan for three minute
time control she went from
the the healthy athlete to the normal
chest streamer the
the caffeinated drinks then you know
yep i see that she's made the full
transition now yes
their final stage our real form yes
exactly
uh three minutes plus one second
increment that
is the new time control um it's it's all
the same it's 15 to nine so that 15
point handicap
coming in handy because uh honestly
it'll probably be
very close going into the bullet if the
current
pace that greg is uh on keeps up
i want to see alex hustle some some blip
games now is the time
yeah i i think uh one thing that has to
be said is any time you have these
uh match-ups where maybe one person's
kind of the the stronger player going in
all it takes is one game one draw one
win just get on the board as alexandra
and the confidence
just goes through the room exactly she
just needs one breakthrough
yep for sure i've seen so many matches
myself where like i'm leading and then
my opponent gets one win
and then just like that they're starting
three four five games in a row
yep love the move e5 here from from greg
i think it's exactly
uh what needed to happen uh b7 is yeah
it's possible to take but rook d1 also
it seems like
her strat now is to just go back to her
her
most comfortable openings i see so
nothing that's been prepared so maybe
that greg won't have anything against
this but
e5 was a great e5 is a good move now
one thing about three minute chess just
to talk about the difference
in the time controls uh one thing that
changes well obviously there's less time
but what that means is that
you can't really uh spend you know a
minute thinking about a move because
that's a third of your time all of a
sudden yes you can't you can't be doing
that so
uh a time advantage in three-minute
chess is gonna be a lot more significant
than in five-minute chess but the other
thing it means is that your time runs
out
a lot quicker so the hope for alexandra
and the way that
she's probably approaching this is hey
let me try to play a little bit quicker
get greg down on time
uh and not you know just survive the
opening and things are going to go a lot
better as i say survive the opening
i'm concerned for her here yeah speaking
of time advantage and i do the same
mistake
it's so sad to see 40 seconds on one
move and i know exactly how it is
because i'll spend like minutes on one
movement blitz
you just get so caught up you think
you're losing
yep so there are a few good options
there for greg
bishop g5 looks very very sturdy because
i mean
how do you stop this very simple tactic
removing the defender
on f6
yeah i i think rook v8
missed this then just a little bit too
defensive from alexandra she needed to
say look you know forget that pawn i'm
already up upon from e5 just
castle you know yeah exactly
yep yep this i mean she's down a minute
here and it's just these opening
issues for alexandra um the games where
she sort of gets out of the opening no
problem it might even be worth it for
her to spend a little extra time in the
opening make sure these things don't
happen
be down on time in the middle game but
at least be in the middle of you
yeah i have to say underestimated greg's
openings i didn't think she'd be finding
killer lines every single game it's very
impressive
yeah it really is it's not easy uh no
matter what
your readings are you know sometimes
i'll play a i'll play a 1500
and they'll get to the middle game it
doesn't matter right yeah exactly
this is uh an impressive impressive
showing
by uh by greg here and that is going to
be taken on d7
with the rook i imagine
yep but you know she can just practice
her speed here when we're down
well more than an exchange but an
exchange was a generous way to put it
yeah
yeah uh an exchange of a queen
as soon as she gets a good opening i
know
i know she can turn the tables but this
game isn't it
that hurts okay it's all right just
shake it off and
new opening new game new try she needs
to keep her head up
yeah yeah well uh greg is actually
getting one point per game
and alexandra is losing one point per
game so she's just entered
the 2099 territory so greg is slowly
feasting on her elo one point at a time
one point for
game well yeah but then again if she
wins one there'll be a lot more juicy
points
andrea did she look at the line tell me
she looked at the line okay look
i don't know she hasn't been up here i
don't think she prepared okay queen
f3 yes finally all right so
i believe here the move is
h wait is h6 just give alexandra the
point right now yes
okay correct 94 correct beautiful
everything nice
nice nice nice okay she's doing it she
remembered finally remember to lie
are we still doing it i i'm going to um
uh okay
i don't know if queen of state was
correct um is it
not gonna lie my memory didn't go that
far okay oh it is wow this is all theory
yup yup
this is correct he could have played the
line that we prepared was bishop e7 here
we take on e5 oh no no i think this is
still correct nevermind sorry yeah
queen is queen takes now and then bishop
e7 and then queen b8 check
and if they block that would be the
drawing line
but something's going astray but white
is white has the advantage so clearly
the line worked in your favor and
greg must have went out of the books
giving her the advantage
wow this is a this is some deep deep
finally for hammer hammer would be proud
this is what hammer's been waiting for
and this is what we need to take hammer
is sitting somewhere in a rocking chair
with coffee
yes you know the smile is just forming
on his face
very satisfied now this is hard because
she's up so this is exactly hammer was
like telling us you know you're
you're up how much of are we here um
i mean material points but we have
a very weird position actually yeah
like two bishops for black he's running
out of ponds but alexandra has almost
all our pawns but no development
yeah that's the issue so we have a big
material advantage it's obviously
it's much better for white even though
something must have went wrong but
the hard part is the lack of development
yep and i i'm not sure what
like how black's supposed to play this
but um keep in mind there's a pin on
this rook
so yeah i know wasn't correct
so yeah no this this move looks very
reasonable from alexandra i think she
needs to play d3
knight e4 like bishop out and just like
long cast yeah quicker start developing
yeah and luckily that's
it's a pretty easy plan for white it's
harder for black so
yeah i wonder if he should bring the
knight back in like knight c6 knight d4
if b4 needs to be played to hit the
knight uh i mean the computer is
certainly favoring white here but
i would say this is the kind of position
that could go either way still because
it just looks like a total mess
oh queen check winning the pond oh but
no the rook e6
but yep no you you don't want to take
this pawn but i would say you probably
want to give that check
and then i don't know like almost like
d3 i want to say is there any problem
with that yeah
bishop h is not quite a threat but what
you might consider is rook takes g2
rook takes g2 bishop h6 i don't know if
that's like a working idea but it
certainly looks tempting to me
ooh i like it i think now it's time for
alex to show some tactics
all right could could you oh well your
idea wouldn't work right because the
queen could just defend the bishop
yeah the queen could just defend the
bishop um i think it's reasonable to
still like maybe go for it and play the
end game after that because
she is up some pawns so that's an option
the other option
is get the bishop out and just like try
to castle yeah especially
when she's well she's actually up on
time but in these short time formats i
think she should just go for the more
comfortable developing moves that takes
less time to calculate she does so good
yeah this is it this is gonna be it
don't throw alex
this is our game okay knight's being hit
now
if knight e4 bishop takes e4 and if you
take
on g6 bishop takes g6 be careful
bishop takes e4 is a winning tactic
bishop c5 now okay takes there is mate
what has to happen i believe it's knight
e7
and the only thing i would say to be
careful of for alexandra is rook
h6 somehow like trying to get the queen
but right now she's got
queen takes e5 and it would be met by
rook takes rook e6
so just bishop or sorry rook h6 be super
careful that queen
i think it's lost after rook h6 rook h6
i feel like there has to be something i
mean
she could also just sack if she really
needs to take the rook in the bishop
yep well you were saying lost for for
white or for black
so you're saying for what yeah it'd be
lost for like
rook age six the queen would be stuck on
each eight if you took the pawn then
okay so yeah i lost for white
yep just because of her her material
advantage
exactly even rook h6 she could just
treat
big fan big fan over here nice move
alexandra
this is it knight is coming in finally
we're the ones
starting to take the queen yep but
greg's not going to go down that easy
f6 uh if rook g8 though there's still
knight f6
okay alexandra actually think this one
check and just exchange
she's thinking she's looking for
something better i i think knight f6
is totally yeah i just got it she's
already up so much material 27 seconds
each i think she made the right decision
there yep
what's it gonna be she gonna trade i
queen h1 let's keep in mind that's the
idea
queen h1 check i mean she could she
could just castle and be
safe i like this move though
yep i like this move i think trade i
think greg
might take the rook on an a1 no no okay
so she's going to give check and castle
maybe and queen takes eight too oh
she didn't trust me too let's go
alexandra okay
she's she's being bold checked i like it
though because she's not scared of
anything
and his time is sticking yep
rook b1 good good i like all of the
defense
queen f5 queen yeah she can defend here
this is it though she's got to get this
game yes it was
all the opening line yep can't take
because then we get check on b7
very nice he's playing super well here
b3 almost looks like a mouse slip i
don't know what that is but
i think he wanted to keep the c file
closed do you want me maybe
nice job by alexandra he's absolutely
yep
just careful here alexandra but you know
you've got this carefully associated
f7 don't play that that's the botest
gambit
not that one okay king's nice and safe
maybe rook a2 rook a2 yeah okay two very
nice
i like it i guess yeah comes a6 so i
would do queen c6 just trade the queens
you know you're gonna win
true true just the queens
she's played so well though yes the eye
is one second
uh-oh let's go
oh very quickly nice finally i told you
it's the shorter time control just she's
celebrating like she just won the match
that's how good it is
she's so happy because it's her first i
mean yeah after 10 losses in a row and a
lot in a
long time control it's been a while an
hour of just defeat so this is a very
important win
and let's let's give alexandra the the
full credit she
deserves because that was a nice that
was a great game
nice preparation she remembered it
andrea and looking at the
second try and that yep that was the
hammer line and you
see what happens when you listen to
hammer exactly
exactly and hey we're back to this
french line right after which i thought
has been going decent for her so
this could be good back-to-back uh
momentum yes
she and now she won't fall for that
tactic twice if he takes on c6 so
yeah beanie on monkey w yeah yeah greg's
got the beanie
uh-oh uh-oh so what happened last time i
think it was
knight c6 here by alexandria and then it
was taken
she should still play because i eh the
tank wasn't bad for her there we go this
is the same thing
yep this looks uh very very reasonable
she wants to this time i think take back
with the
bishop instead she didn't have a good
time with her queen there
yeah even though we liked the idea
now i think alexander needs to adjust
though her her setup has been like
bishop out 97
and like h6 and i think i mentioned last
time when when i see b3
i'm not sure that i like go for the
exact yeah exactly
which what would you even suggest
because it's not very easy to defend the
g7
i mean i guess knight f6 same thing yeah
i think like knight f6
uh bishop e7 or maybe even bishop on d6
um
is totally fine but knight f6 against
the bishop on b2
looks very reasonable to me you don't
need h6 as much
you know yeah oh she still goes 97
yeah i like the knight f6 a little bit
better i wonder if there was
no i don't think there was any sack yeah
i don't think she liked knight f5 and in
general like that's the reason you play
knight e7
oh yeah what it's going to come down to
is i think greg's just going to put his
bishop on b2
his bishop is going to go back to d3 uh
at some point if it gets hit
he's still pushing h6 and let's not
forget andrea she's going to have the
same
issue to deal with are you comfortable
castling that's all
hey she thinks there we go she did it
perfect now this is good
no more threats all i can say is
uh from what i've seen so far from
alexandra's
chest i think she went into the break
and she looked at a few lines
and it seems to be paying off so far
yeah i think this is a good start
i think so too
because at the end of the day we are i'm
cheering for a competitive match i want
things to be decided in the bullet
and if yeah like that it looked like it
was going to be a blowout so alexander
getting on the board there is huge
for the match and with her 15 point
handicap it is now
16 to 10. so it's it's heating up
a4 okay stopping b5 there um
greg did and if you play bishop like i
guess like bishop to c6 or if you move
that bishop
off the e6 pawn better believe greg is
thinking about a sacrifice
something or other which is hard so like
black in this position how are you even
supposed to improve that and if you
can't even move your
your bishop that's already very
defensive and isn't this allowing
well 1966 i think is is pretty fair uh
yeah no knight c6 is actually
okay i still think the bishop on b2 is
gonna be really strong like for example
i don't know knight takes knight
followed by queen g4
just as an example make a threat against
the pawn on g7
how do you defend that whether you're
playing e5
as a sample line like knight takes
bishop takes queen g4
let's say you play like e5 white
sacrifices on d6
black takes back and i can just see
something
bad i was gonna say i don't even know if
you could take with the bishop because i
thought maybe
the sack would work but he didn't take
anyway
he started with queen g4 and
i don't know now i have a beautiful move
yeah 95
and taking off her his bishop pair might
yep 95 definitely looks uh
like that's why i wanted to take the
knight first right on c6 and then go
queen g4
yeah and knight c6 i think she had to
take maybe with the queen or the pawn
which is much weaker
but now i think she has the advantage
totally agree 95 i think greg just sort
of forgot for a second you can see by
the camera he's a little flustered oh i
love greg's expressions
i like watching a very you know highly
emotional chest yeah exactly
greg like just guys are really so
passionate that you can see the reaction
it's always it's always even better when
the cam is just their entire
face because they're so zoomed into the
game yep yep 95 so he's gonna just have
to admit that
uh yeah bishop's gonna be taken and nice
but we still have to be careful though
because that bishop on b2 and that queen
is still a very strong player
absolutely absolutely now unfortunately
for greg
he had to move the queen off the g file
you would have loved to cast
nowhere to go though yeah now that she
has a bishop pair she can control
all the important squares the g3 square
the g4 square nowhere for the queen to
go
yeah after e5 it's interesting um i
guess knight
f5 is sort of the the natural move
um yeah it's opened up her bishop air
might not be lasting very long
i think knight f3 there's also a big
case for that move um and he might even
prefer it
uh just considering he's also more
passive
yep it keeps a little bit more pieces on
the board yeah and he does go for that
f6 uh good move by alexandra the move
she had to play to defend e5
and greg i figured he's hoping to get in
there
yeah but that bishop i i think 9 of 5
would have been better trying to
force her to trade one of her bishops
because then
totally agree yeah she's sorry
f5 is the move now like that's what
greg wants to play
winning now uh queen f7 was not it
oh wow it's it's that botez blind spot
you know
yeah you don't see knight h6
man that's a killer
but uh 30 seconds wow
she really had this game too but both
players are playing really well right
now
yeah given the position but
unfortunately the position that we're
given is probably one that is winning
for greg yeah yep
uh probably a flag oh she gets the move
off but greg's gonna have no problem
taking that rub
basically going for mate oh yeah she
can't even take back
no okay yeah this is just designable
bishop d4 here
yep she's still going
yeah it's a few more checks it's the
tactics it's the tactics
now that that game was really good for
alexandra
and well i think what we noticed is what
i'm noticing is the time is just like
disappearing
these guys are in time pressure like in
the middle game
yeah they're both thinking a lot they're
both thinking a lot
yeah for alex that makes her miss a few
more tactics
and then for greg maybe he plays a
little bit more passively than the
the aggressive move that could give him
the advantage
yep okay so new opening and i was
waiting for this
i was waiting for this she doesn't play
e4 so yeah
what's gonna happen this is a a very
very clear uh flaw in the plan yeah it's
okay she's transposed to d4
hey whoa greg just blundered big time
wait a minute bishop takes f7 hello
oh my god somebody notices because
oh my goodness oh no this is basically
nobody even knows
i i just have to point that come on
alexandria
oh my goodness i need to be fair as a
not e4 player you probably see those
you're probably seen those patterns a
lot but for me i didn't even spot it
in the first few seconds either yeah
it's uh
something to always be on the lookout
for when you see an early bishop g4 and
your bishop's on
c4 it's like just give it a double check
every time
yep wow that would have been nice if she
would have seen that but i'm surprised
like greg fell for it
that's what i'm saying that's what's
really weird about that is that greg is
like hey you're not an ep player and
then he blends a tactic in three moves
maybe he doesn't play e5 either
maybe they both don't know their lines
here that's possible
and i think that's might even be the
case but greg probably said look if we
both don't know what we're doing
i'm probably better off yep exactly
let's see if that holds true so
alexandra's got the bishops here
but uh her bishops need uh they need
some taken care of here and queen d1 big
fan of that move
what happens after knight c5
bishop e3 yeah maybe bishop e3 d4
yeah i was going to say is a very
unfortunately very likely uh
tactic to fall into is there any way out
here
i don't think so you almost have to go
like this is brutal
yeah this this looks pretty rough
this looks a little bit rough here yeah
she just
needed a safe move like bishop c2 and
and even with hammers no i i guess
you're trying to be tricky you know
trying to pin the knight but
on on this time control i don't know how
much time she has for tricks especially
when greg is better at tactics
and greg just did the equivalent of a
mic drop he
took the beanie and just dropped it on
the ground yeah it was
like giving us a show here this is
wearing
uh is he wearing like an i don't know
like an alice in wonderland tablecloth
like what what's
his neck there it's quite the fashion
statement
from uh greg it's a little colored shirt
um but you know what i'm gonna say is
the hard part when you're playing
against someone so much higher rated
like
2700 you expect that they don't miss any
tactics so
i just feel like it's safe for like you
know avoid going for tricky moves like
bishop e3 and just play safe a nice
bishop c2 because
they will see it faster than we do yeah
that's a good point
um now i don't know if this is a good or
a bad thing
but there is a uh there's a lot of
people playing guess the move
on chess.com and i see someone rated 400
who's guessed almost all the moves and
that's a good sign 400 maybe they just
never
either they're not rated 400 or some
people in this game
are rated 400. yeah one of the two is
one of the two
wait where is this guess the moves
in chess.com in live chess yeah oh i see
you can play guess the move follow along
in live chats
cool yep
rook d8 and that's just a full extra
piece also a full extra minute
for greg here yep not our game
but doesn't look like it but she's still
in it and i totally agree with that
given that it's it's shorter time
control
more likely to have some blunders
botez has got to somewhere rating back
as well you know back over 2100
yeah true see we were talking about
those one by one by one point
but hey one win look at us we're back at
21 13.
exactly yeah it's all about the rating
at the end
exactly queen d5 looking for trades
that's exactly what you want to do when
you're up material
and conversely that's exactly what you
want to do when you're down material
don't trade avoid the
yeah i like queen g4 she's looking to
maybe double the rooks get pawn to b5
kick that knight a little bit
yeah down a piece but if she could just
put him a little if she could catch up a
little bit on time
oh
that's a strong strong idea uh to just
play each five i think
rook to c1 had to happen for
alexandria there yeah oh
oh maybe she was trying to go for no
time to check she doesn't have a draw
though
because she doesn't have a draw i mean
she's doing this on purpose
losing the rook yeah i don't think it's
gonna work but
it's a fun try yeah i mean when you're
already already lost
might as well try with something a
little bit more tricky
like if greg had if greg had maybe 20
seconds here
yeah but um you're
you've got some chances but with greg
got a minute and 20 seconds exactly
i don't trust it as much yeah time
really makes all the difference though
yep and we look at that uh game or match
clock rather
there's you know 20 minutes left ticking
down in the
uh three plus one portion right now
so uh you know the time for still a
bunch more games
yes
yeah unfortunately that full rook down
is is hurting here although
one thing that's kind of funny in chess
is it's actually really hard to win a
game
without a pawn without really hard to
win without without if greg loses these
two pawns he could be up a rook but it's
just
really hard to win without pawns yeah i
guess like if you ever
defend your king then you know you don't
give them any mates threat
but they would eventually just find some
tactics and win more material
yep but it can be it can be very
difficult you you underestimate in this
position that like
if black doesn't have those pawns it's
not so easy yeah
very true but unfortunately i don't
think he's gonna be losing either
all right yep yes
that's good enough there well now
oh yeah and unfortunately she's never
going to get to play that
e4 that attack that hammer prepared
again because i is going to be
playing d5 against e4
yep absolutely rook to rook to g6
and uh basically in this position i
think that
uh he's gonna take that bishop alexander
was down on time anyway the score right
now is 16
to 12 and we are coming up to our
little halftime break here andrea people
get a refresh but
although the last refresh we had i was
like okay alexandra needs this but
in this case do you think maybe greg is
kind of happy i
still think the bullet portion she will
pull it off i have a lot of hope and you
know
the issue here is still tactics but if
she adjusts to this and instead of going
for tricks play a little bit safer
could still you know she started with a
win one win to two losses isn't too bad
so i'm still staying very hopeful
yep absolutely well 16 to 12 is your
score line given that 15 point handicap
that alexandra started with
and we're gonna take like i said our
halftime break so don't go anywhere
we're back with the rest of the
three minute portion and then andrea's
favorite the bullet
happens after that we'll be right back
after the break
so
and welcome back everybody to apparently
our very covet conscious
uh scream andrea yeah i don't know if
this is gonna make them play
better because you know it's harder to
breathe and sometimes you get a little
bit sweaty playing chess your heart
starts speeding up but
you know i respect it where we're
supporting taking health precautions yep
and and alexandra is the front runner
there she's got
she's got the the mask on there fully
approved
and greg is wow he's matching it
you know i'm curious i'm curious how
long they're gonna keep these masks on
yeah actually that's that's a fun idea
uh andrea how long do you think
alexandra
keeps that mask on i'm gonna say okay if
she loses i think she'll take it off
so the first game she loses it comes off
yes
okay and i i will say that
with um 18 minutes left
in this uh in this three minute 18 19
minutes left in the three-minute segment
i will say that the mask comes off
um before 12 minutes left okay
all right let's see whenever that is
let's see who's right
well they hopped straight into the games
they're eager
um there we go yeah greg has got the uh
quick castle and actually alexandra is
basically playing
like a hippo i i like what she's doing
because she remembers that
he's he was winning these fiance
positions by breaking through her king
so now with h5
she's not even giving him a chance to
start pushing h4g4
well he can but not as as a girl so
we get a position where these extremely
talented players have all played
a5 h4 h5 and andrea's like yeah i love
what she's doing
i i know it looks very counter-intuitive
you know you're taught
pawns in the center develop knights and
bishops before you push side pawns
but sometimes you know especially of
course
when you're playing three minutes you're
uh you might go a little bit astray
from the opening basics but they might
pay off
yep no that's certainly the case that in
three minutes and then uh even more so
in one minute
chess that all a lot of the principles
that you might follow
you know poof out the window a lot of
the time yeah
of course very relatable like just
stacking a piece
just to make them think you know and i'm
sure we'll be seeing some of those
but so how do you think do you think
this is going to pay off for alex
trying this h5 a5 um
i'll be honest no no i don't think the
other side i'll say
cupcakes perfect we have a good bet
going on yeah we might as well start
gambling just kidding just kidding we
don't get it
no none of that no just in video games
yeah just video games and masks on
everybody good stuff yes
um they've still got the mask on they do
yeah
greg is looking a lot more somehow
comfortable in his than out
yeah i know alex looks like
it looks like she's about to go into a
medical center or something
so serious yeah very serious greg's
looked like
you know the one that you might wear
exactly like he's going to the mall he's
picking
up some some things looking fashionable
in his cute mask
alex is here to uh murder
yeah and for the win and uh with knight
before
in knight takes d3 i think alexandra
should be happy with yeah just happened
i'm definitely a fan of it i mean
hammer is a fan of it and luckily i
always like this when things are getting
locked up in the center and you can
castle
safely it's giving a lot of time to
finally have time to attack his king's
side
and one thing that uh greg i don't think
we'll almost ever do in this game
is play the move e5 but i wanted to
point it out that's something that
alexandra is like
dying to see she really wants to
encourage e5 so her knight
could jump to the f5 square exactly
although sometimes e5 can be really
annoying because
it's gonna be hard to develop your dark
squared bishop and it's completely
trapped in so at some point it might
come in handy
but there are bishop maneuvers on the f8
square and other ideas
yep and i think alexandra is probably
looking to launch like
b5 b4 and meanwhile greg is looking to
play
g4 which is why he just brought the
queen e yeah and unfortunately
the i don't think there's a piece she
can bring to defend it
um no uh one thing i don't know if it's
is uh good enough but one thing is that
after b5 before
the knight is actually trapped at the
moment yeah i was going to say an
interesting idea
maybe was like queen d6 so g4
push f6 and the knight can't take
and then she always has bishop e8 if she
needs to defend
yeah bishop on e8 is actually a very
cool resource it guards all those
important light squares from
from the back row yeah i don't like her
time though i'm not happy about this 30
seconds and
she's fixing her hair on her time no no
no
this is not how we take care of our time
right okay
now i'm gonna be careful here she traded
those double bonds which
may have been better to keep the
position closed and placed slowly when
she's down a minute
but yeah basically okay
not sure about bishop d2 um i definitely
disagree with that i think he should
have taken the bishop and just moved the
knight off the last yeah now her bishop
is the monster
now it might actually pay off that she
opened it up
yep and if if greg ever plays e5 it will
hit the bishop and block it but it gives
away those squares we've been talking
about
i think she has a great position but
with 14 seconds and one second increment
she has to be has to be pre-moving
almost everything it's still the middle
game and she has almost 10 seconds
yep the you might say oh alex has this
game she just has to play fast but that
is so hard to do
she can start trying some safe pre-moves
but they'll just get punished
man this is three speed yeah and
actually just start preventing some
trades maybe
yeah get that thing moving on you'll
take though i don't i don't know if you
will
yep king a1 totally reasonable
seven seconds oh man
i know she could all disposition but ah
this the
time was so bad very good move knight d4
the king is uh always back rank issues
on a1
all right we're gonna see how well she
can play just one second for move
she has a great chance here in my
opinion yes great chance greg is going
to look to be tricky here
he's down upon and even if he wasn't
down upon his position is not good that
king is vulnerable
all right okay uh i think
i like that move it was a blunder but i
i don't know why that
was a blender i liked it yeah i mean it
probably has to do with this because
uh rook takes f7 is going to lead to a
checkmate oh
wow so she does this and there's knight
takes e6 here
with check
so that's probably why but uh it didn't
i agree it looked it looked energetic it
looked okay but
wow oh my goodness but it it's the time
man
so you take the mask off i was right i
was right
and i was also right you were right
about the bombs
that well actually i think she got into
a good position so maybe the pawns
helped her but the time was the best
i was right about that but i mean i said
it would be taken off before
uh 12 minutes true truth we're both
right
i think we both had a feeling that was
coming straight off we're both
in the right for both of the the bits
whether the pawn structure was good and
whether the mask would come off
yeah but greg is leaving is on we're
we're getting all the wins out here we
yeah alexandra needs to be getting these
now yeah true
we need to pass on some of our luck or
good intuition
his mask is off too maybe he saw
alexandria he was like oh no i got a
match
i think greg just likes matches matching
he's a showman you know
what looks best for the stream
guys calm yourselves this is not strip
chest those are just masks
okay they're taking off masks that's all
oh my all right let's see
what is this opening grunfeld this is
new right we haven't seen this
yeah i'm trying to think did we prepare
the grunfeld i don't know if we did i
don't think we did
i don't know if we did either yeah true
nobody knows so let's find out
but she has to be learning from that
speed
well um what we see here is a big thing
from alexandra
already in the opening bishop d5
check i'm guessing she's going to take
that
uh it's fourth to take and i
i why can't she just play a move like
knight f3
defending everything absolutely she can
absolutely spend too much time looking
for tricks again
when she's playing the natural moves
one thing about knight f3 so like let's
say takes knight takes
um if you go knight f3 i guess greg
might take on d4
and if you have to take with the pawn
it's yeah it's a fine position
but it is a weakness exactly it is a
weakness
yeah sometimes the isolated pawn can be
i always learn it's either strength or
weakness because
sometimes it's not very if you can
defend it it can end up being quite
strong
but yep she also had to double check
that she wasn't losing a bishop to queen
e4 check
she would have bishop e3 and now she's
castled so look it might be a weakness
might not be the best i think greg is
happy with this position but yeah
she's out of the opening she's not like
you know at 30 seconds
we're just getting down a minute we need
to know speed we need
if i was there i'd be like sweet sweet
speed i'd be telling her reminding her
but
yeah that that's what you need you need
a good buddy a good wings
exactly all right
yeah it's still a pretty comfortable
position like you know she has isolated
pawn
i guess he's probably gonna bring like a
rook d8 but
yep so i i like bishop h6 as a move um
trade off that bishop try to get the
queen out there as well
that is a very nice idea i i feel like
it's kind of
hard to find i don't think she'd see it
b3 nice covering c4 um so here i want to
avoid trades if i'm white
end game good for greg very good for
greg why were you suggesting bishop h6
if you want to avoid trades
i should say i want to avoid uh major
peace trades
it's a better clarification so queens
and rooks i'd like to keep on the board
uh so this trade might actually be good
for her then
yep yeah i definitely like it because
now the dark skies around the king are
weak and her queen is easily set up
and so is her knight so she she might
have an attacking plan there it goes
there we go
yeah i think she might have just jumped
in with that queen a little bit early um
i would like to see the rooks build up
maybe double
i'd also really like to see h4 h5 i'd
like to push that pawn up the board
yep i think here with down a minute she
has
to go for the natural moves that would
be a very nice plan though
so i'd like to move the queen and play
h4h5 that's basically my plan
i wonder i think she'll find it maybe
she normally finds those type of plans
especially because she knows in time
pressure
you just need to find a way to create
another attack so she uses that plan a
lot
you know brooks c2 would be a funny
blender here dropping a whole rook on d8
but he's not
nope he doesn't greg never misses the
tactics except that one beginner bishop
g4
like he never misses them except yeah
except once
knight h2 so aggressive idea knight g4
looking to attack those squares and
sometimes after knight g4 you can even
like
sack on d5 with the rook and you know
like use the the
oh yeah and try to fork but he's
preventing it right away
yep and he's looking to play rook c to
d8 and attack
the d4 pawn rook b5 i really don't like
that move it's just you attack upon it
gets defended what did you what did you
really do there
exactly i think maybe she should ride
like well i guess that the h
movie the h pawn plan doesn't work
anymore because of the knight on f6 so
she couldn't have even played
queen g3 and h4 so knight d5 here
it's just such a funny move because now
the rook on b5 is literally trapped like
it's just not
a6 is going to win the rook alexander's
rook b5 was like
completely the wrong idea yeah a5 and
then let's say if
a6 you technically lose your rope yeah
a5 but at least she could sack for the
night and try to win the pawn
yep she should take on b6 here just to
be tricky
he couldn't wonder he should just move
the rook
to b8 and then i think it's just she's
down a minute again like i think if he
had equal time she could probably
swindle but
this one minute oh like it's it's
happening again
yep she's thinking so much it's
just the pawn we don't have time yeah
this unfortunately her queen ended up on
h4
which like blocked her big plan of h48
yeah exactly and now that the knight was
gone that plan would have been very
useful
so move the rook up maybe like rookie
four
or key four rook f4 rook h4
unfortunately an hg5 doesn't really make
any threats
rookie four king h2 i like that as well
just yeah
oh my goodness these two seconds
yeah and there goes that's so so
rough i'm curious where she's losing all
her time it seems to be like
in the middle game but every game ends
up being and i do it so much myself
as well yeah it's definitely in the
opening the middle game
it is it is very early on and it's if
that's where it creeps up on you you
don't even notice it sometimes until the
last
30 seconds yeah and then you're like
wait oh i'm down a whole minute yep that
always happens to me
well i whenever i'm streaming i like to
blame the chat you know i was just
trying to play in the chat
always blame the chat but hang on your
partner or the chat
it's never your fault for losing on time
it's always someone else's fault for
distracting you but
unfortunately alex doesn't have anyone
to blame on this round
yeah unfortunately the camera's on but
she's not exactly streaming so it
doesn't count
she'd blame me if i was there
and uh i can see greg's got the the
reflection
of the board in his glasses so yeah just
trying to study the position through
them
that's interesting what do we have here
another isolated pawn for alexandra but
i recognize this i'm pretty sure this is
more or less theory
she's getting faster she's finally
playing the the first
10 moves quicker yep she knows this
position i can tell
and now uh maybe knight e3 yeah hitting
the pawn on d5 getting
active there also maybe intending knight
f5 hitting
the g7 pawn and the bishop on e7 which i
think
greg would be happy to capture yeah
and the amount of time left in the three
minute portion
is just around four minutes now andrea
so wow it could be the last game race
probably is the last game in that case
yeah but in case they finish with 10
seconds left and they start a new one it
will count oh
interesting yeah but i don't think i
mean
let's say one of them alex gets under
last seconds i'll be three minutes and
greg will definitely spend more than a
minute on the game
so i think he'll be the last one but i
really hope alex can
maybe pull you know she's off to a
better start maybe she can end on a win
go into the bullet portion feeling
better
yep absolutely c3 uh by greg now
alexander's position is not bad but
it's just one of those isolated pawn
positions where it's easy to get into
this funk of like i don't
really know what to do and then you
start overthinking it
and all she needs to do is is for
example the move she did that's fine 96
that's a good move
just need more of that just gotta have
more confidence yeah i feel like she
does just have some pawn weaknesses like
the b7 pawn
and her pawns aren't reconnected
so bishop e5 threat uh d5 pawn
and she's meeting that with an active
response bishop c5 saying look
you can't take that because then f2 is
hit as a result
that's a nice move i like bishop c5
[Music]
and um positions are very difficult yeah
you just have to play slowly i think
here just slow improving moves
i don't even know here what you should
do maybe it's like rookie eight and wait
yeah rookie eight i think he's a fine
move uh i don't know
b6 uh queen d7 oh but she wants to be
aggressive okay yep she's hitting f2 but
um if the knight takes on e6 she has no
problem like taking back with the pawn
connecting her pawns and solving her
isolated pawn issue
yep okay i don't think g3 was a good
choice for him you know
we talked about it a few times dark dark
squared bishop don't want to put your
pawns there
okay and queen but maybe it's a strength
okay
okay now after f4 i think that she's
basically got queen g6 as a mean option
all the way back to d8 ah this one is a
one move fork
it is a one move after this one what
after f5 i think there's queen
g5 to like sort of stay in the game
yeah but i don't think i don't think we
can i think h4 after queen g5
is the killer move yeah yeah i think
it's h4
and now the queen is almost has to go
back to e7
now if she keeps speed though you know
it's just a pawn for a knight if she
if she plays this faster like here she
obviously has no other squares in e7 so
she should play it quickly
and keep her time advantage yeah i mean
now
is what greg is thinking about but he's
just gonna take the piece and i think go
queen g4 afterwards
queen g4 hits e6 hits g7
oh i don't know why she didn't take
because
queen g queen g4
i guess there's not many ways to defend
the pawn otherwise in trade
yeah i think she's intending g5 here or
i hope she is because it sort of looked
like
that was her plan just get trapped the
bishop but unfortunately like
g4 yeah there's queen g4 there's knight
takes d5 there's knight f5
there's like a lot of night jumps
together yeah i think taking on e6 was
pretty important to defend that d5 pawn
and well there's 24 seconds left oh well
we might have time for it really depends
alexander's got 13.3
there's 16 seconds left ticking down
six seconds i don't think she'll resign
in the next 16 seconds
no okay so there's gonna there's gonna
be no more games
this is gonna be the last i mean i don't
know three minute game
yeah oh oh may as well end with a
is she going to resign after this she
can resign or she's going to play on
she's going to let out a little smurf no
it's time
time is up already oh that was so close
so we started the five minute portion
with the protest gambit
and we ended three minutes all style
points just for style now in her defense
i will point out that the bishop was on
c5 the whole game
pinning the knight and i think she just
forgot at the very end she moved it to
d6
and yeah that's why she played queen e6
but hey there's there's no excuses for
focusing true
yeah you know
it's it's gonna be her time to swindle
i'm telling you the bullet portion she's
gonna shine i know it
okay well you heard it here first guys
from you know one beautiful speaking
about another
she's gonna shine in the bullet the
score is currently
16 points for alexander beautes she
started with
15 points handicapped she got a win
in that was a big momentum shift she
needed that to make this close
she's up by one again she's still
leading though yes
exactly she's in the lead point team
alexandra
and after this we get into the very
exciting
bullet portion one minute chess one
minute for the whole game plus one
second increment per move
so we will be back with that very
exciting format to
determine the winner here in this match
between alexander beautes and greg
shahadi so
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
after this
and welcome back everybody hopefully uh
everyone who was here before the break
is still here and ready for the bullet
potion but
before we get into that i just wanted to
remind everybody that
chess.com puzzle week which i was uh
reminding andrea about might be a good
idea for alexandra
um yeah honestly for the both of us
well boy do i have the thing for you
andrea january 4th to
uh is going to be puzzleweek on
chess.com um
you know for those that are basically in
vacation mode and have no idea what day
it is that is tomorrow
so mark your calendars there's basically
going to be all sorts of different
versions of the chess.com puzzles
there's tactics there's puzzle rush
there's so many different ways to do
puzzles on chess.com survival mode etc
and over the five days there's going to
be different formats featured
it's going to be your favorite
commentators such as danny wrench
bigfoot who's been commentating a lot
for chess.com
and the one and only maurice ashley so
you can see there just some of your
favorite streamers on screen there's
going to be lots lots more but
it'll just be sort of like a fun week
andrea with uh you know good
good uh puzzles for for everyone and
practice that
honestly we all need yeah you can watch
with them
and train with them at the same time
yeah
yeah so that'll be fun that's starting
tomorrow but right now
we have uh they are changing every scene
every every round look at that the the
outfit
outfit changes and it looks like greg
for the one
minute section he he is ready to that
makes sense
you know this is gonna be the most uh
difficult
workout of the entire match so you gotta
get in your right workout gear
yep oh great greg is looking looking d's
right there and we're we're into it one
minute plus one second
all of his crossfit training just for
this bullet match
yeah is that a shoulder or a bicep no i
know who knows
jeez greg's 2500. all right and it's
begun
the speed it's coming strong let's see
yeah and i i already like
alexandra's opening just because i don't
see any issue with it this is all she
needs
yes this is all she needs we just we
have this isolated pawn
game after game but you know maybe it's
not gonna be weakness in this game
the bishop p3 is very interesting i
don't know if it's good to allow him to
take but i guess i would solve the
isolated pawn
yep and you guys can see just by the
ratings featured on screen
uh the bullet section is gonna be a lot
closer exactly as as indicated here
23.77
25 22. yeah which if if there wasn't
a one point difference like it could
have been very equal but
with almost equal odds it's still a
little bit
rough but you know alex is very quick so
maybe
she'll the underdog will pull through
yeah the queen b6 check uh
looking to take on b2 yeah
here greg's tactics will definitely be
shining through also
so i think that it's really risky to
take this pawn uh not only is d6
in the cards but there's rook b1 and
after rook b1 the queen has to take on
a3 and then there's like knight d5
exactly so i i kind of like this yeah
it totally underestimated the point of
the the strength of that past pawn
i wonder if no 97 would just be a draw
given the queen for the two rooks okay
and there is going to be queen d4
now i think she wants knight e7 here
yeah that's why she tried to block this
file
and he can't take there goes his rook so
he's just going to leave the knight
there
and i think she's going to take that
back yeah
she's got a strong defunct but she has
to watch out for dark squares bishop
bishop bishop has won queen g3
she's got to move the king there you go
good no no queen g1 much
much better than king i think okay i'm a
little concerned
rook to b1 is what greg wants she's
going to continue defending
very quick and she does have a little
bit of a time edge which never really
happened so far so
wow now this is this is looking very
promising yep
now i think she should take the rook and
then solve her queen like her queen
being on g1 she can't move it it's a
non-participant
there we go can i say i wonder if you
could grab that a7 pawn
yep nice this is good because now
everything around our king is descended
that bishop is holding it all together
black doesn't have any threats
yep and the black bishop is stuck on
like don't let alexandria get a queen
duty on
yes exactly it's acting like a pawn
this however um i think
queen e7 is gonna be played yes bishop
no we're gonna lose
our main strength the past pawn and
she's spending her time okay
it's okay there's another one yeah we
got another one just replace them
yep unfortunately if she loses that then
it really is gonna be
tough bishop c4
just keeping the pressure on f7 very
important
yep just you should just go back and
forth because i don't think you would
want the draw she just went back to
before oh she blundered her bishop she
forgot that this oh
man ah she's doing so well it's just
these little blunders
but let's be clear alexandra and this
bullet uh portion is gonna be
way more competitive like this is going
to be very close i think
as you can see yep and even here i don't
know
well no okay this one's over now never
mind yeah
the best you could hope for is some sort
of stalemate but yeah
don't see it happening yep
well i i thought she should have just
went back to b5
instead of bringing her queen down after
that rook attack tried to repeat
moves to save her time right
and is he finally going to move that
pawn up the board
oh queen f4 struggling to get to the
checkmate
yeah he's i don't know what he's doing
he seems a little scared of the time
ticking down he's like always making a
move to get more time
yeah exactly oh all right she resigned
the other
i guess i'm checking me too was coming
so that's only game one it's 16
all right now all right now it really
starts now
it really starts here we go greg with
the white pieces
alexandra going for the fiance king's
indian style
i i liked a lot how she played that last
game but of course she is more likely to
blunder than greg
so and blunders bullet is known for that
yep and this is gonna be a position
where i think he's gonna take the knight
with the bishop on g5 and then reroute
this knight
the long way to like e1 c2 e3
d5 something like that interesting
you don't think is he gonna occupy the
d5 squares with his knight
i think that's the plan i was gonna say
he's probably gonna toss in b4
on the way to that idea but yeah i think
eventually ending up
on d5 is the plan yep now the two
knights are strong defending each other
yeah these positions i always try to
keep the light square diagonal blocked
because as soon as you open it up
white's g2 bishop is just too strong
while ours is still locked in by e5
yeah so this move a6 i don't think
alexandra needed to play it at all like
i don't think there's any need i think
she should go on the other side f5 like
f5 yeah did you use your bishops over
there yes i think
you know a6 you wanted to stop knight b5
knight b5 would you try to trade your
bishop for the knights or just
continue defending try to defend
if i could do it i would always try to
not give up my my light square bishop
where it possibly yeah
that that's why and i kind of understand
a6 because just allowing that night b5
looks like you're giving them
space but that would have also stopped
rook b6
d3 is threatened there's a one move
attack bishop on c6 is super solid right
here by the way guarding everything
uh she kind of had this in her last game
with the bishop on f3 so
this is good we need to see more king
side pressure f5
but that's solid solid strategy here
i think she wanted to play f5 and she
was like wait my queen's honestly yeah
exactly let me move that out of the way
but now see going back and forth might
make him make some mistakes because
i trading the bishop should be a little
bit better for her and that knight is
also cutting off his rook
so i think her going back and forth
maybe inclined him to play a little bit
weaker yeah this is this is fine for for
alexander she's getting and i knew that
he was gonna sack there right
why did he do that because he's a bullet
yep very
true ah and she's half the sign and
there's the tactics
there's the rook right back yep and eyes
up upon
okay well now
this is now they're going to take on a6
this is very rough
she could try like yup f4 some bullet
tricks but there's not much there going
you really know your sister yeah she
could try this nonsense f4 yep there it
is
just to like you know give a check and
hope he messes and misses something
that's the bullet strategy but we know
greg is a bit more of a defensive
passive player when he sees the clean on
f5
he plays f3 the eval bar just dropped oh
my goodness take the rook
queen makes b8 and queen check and
there's a draw oh my god
she mouse slipped oh no she dropped her
look
and then a queen
you know what we blame this on the mouse
this wasn't oh wow they're eager to go
again all right
that was really upsetting she had a draw
but you know that's a bullet
there's gonna be mouse slips
oh man so i don't think it was a draw
like a perpetual shack force but it was
just her queen was gonna yeah her queen
was gonna get in there and the threat of
perpetual i think it was dead even as
you said
man she was so close wow
the one time she finally sees the tactic
he doesn't the mouse slip
yeah so as you can see alexandra has
her chances greg even when he's so up
even when
you know the f4 like bullet trick it
worked right it didn't
happen in bullets
yes the so far the first two games were
very very close
another protest game but right when she
had the
perpetual movie or the yeah hangings
like oh
i i mean i think after black took the
rook and she didn't give the check it
was already a win so you know that boat
is gamble it was just another style
point because she already knew it was
lost
and i hope she's not thinking about that
uh as much as i am
i'm still thinking about the last game
so i hope she's forgotten
we move on we drop a queen you forget
about it there's just normal life around
here
i already forgot about it
okay so d3 hanging alexandra also down
about 15
16 seconds like that's quite cool
because he has the attack here
it's interesting though because it's a
blocked position where both
players have the bishops which don't do
well in blocked positions so
but this pawn structure of whites i'm
not a fan of
yeah so i think i was going to say i
thought she was going to
take the bishop and go bishop takes f5
like sacked the brookfield
oh that was a very nice tactic and then
take on f5 but because she didn't do
that that bishop on e4
is insanely strong he got his bishop
outside of the pawns the most important
thing here yep oof
this looks tough as soon as the rook
like gets down to c2 and the queen gets
in
it could be over very quick but
alexander on the attack
trade yep keeping pressure
nice maybe she could try like rook c1
d6 yeah oh yeah she's looking at d6 or
maybe rook to f1
get over to make some threats 10 seconds
rook f1 there's maybe bishop f6
she needs to make goodness oh are she
gonna flag
what she now slipped again a drum
okay this one we do not forget okay
that's like i need to go give her my
mouse i don't know i think we have the
same mouse i don't know
oh my goodness two mouse lifts in a row
but i mean luckily
okay actually the last mouse slip did
throw the game but this one didn't so
it's not
as devastating but you know the one of
the tough things
about being known for both gambits is
that when you
really do actually mouse slip people are
like yeah okay
yeah exactly but there's another protest
nice try that one well sometimes i don't
see him when she plays them but that one
since i saw it at the same time i know
it was a mouse slip
but we will like be playing a game and
we will both we'll be playing a team
match and not even realize we're hanging
our queen together so
just another sister strength yep just
remember
as long as you're on the same page it
might not be a good page but you're on
the scene
yeah exactly all right
trying new things every game which it's
definitely for the better since he was
crushing us
in the opening lines we did know yep and
in bullet that's exactly the way
you want to do things right now she's
trying to basically toss the jeep on off
the board
the last moves have prepared very
interesting i like the more aggressive
idea here
but he is a very good defender so
okay so rook h1 defending um
queen c6 looking for g4 and i think he's
going to take that pawn
yep he has to and now knight
takes he could probably take the pawn
and taking on f3
isn't a threat
but it's okay no need to spend too much
time on this well knight takes g5 rook
takes h5 and
yeah i guess she's she's not too happy
with that okay so she takes it
oh i think we blundered now well i mean
rook g6 or knight knight f6 are both
fine um
i think he's got a better position but
uh it is it's still playable
yeah yeah actually it wasn't a blender
okay actually maybe her tricky line was
actually better
i thought our rook would be too
misplaced but it's not too bad
he's not taking that pawn
h4 i i like h4 in general yeah better
than giving it for free with no capital
definitely take it open up the g
file yes take it yeah eight seconds
we need to get it i think she's doing
fine here she's down upon but
she's she's very okay it's just the time
the time the time
i would make sure to play a move like
king b8 or
whoa and be more aggressive
uh i'm not second
yeah it's gonna get checked and i bet
you will cause a
flag maybe queen g5 is a fantastic move
queen takes h5 rook g8
that's a tactic streaming for you uh
she knows it too that is a tactic rook
g8
that's exactly what you'll find in
puzzle week starting tomorrow
yes it is man these games are close but
it's
she's a little bit too slow he's getting
still too much of a time advantage in
the beginning
yeah the thing is all of these are are
close but
who's getting them that's that's what
exactly
reminders that's exactly the the type of
rating difference like you can
play so equal and then just those 10
lasting moves are going to
crush you and that's where their
experience shows off
yep so i think here you could consider
taking on
b2 and then queen b4 check and win the
knight back on c5
that was an interesting line yeah i
think they're both
not playing their usual openings yeah
just going
greg's just going for safe he's got two
bishops he's saying look i just
developed
yeah you can go wrong here but it's also
easy to play on white's part
he doesn't have a bishop player though
yeah a6 i mean greg is a little bit
better here uh bishops are good
center is a big center but definitely
not a bad position for alexander at all
yes there should be two knights trying
to push c4
or f4 or even better okay so f4 creates
some weaknesses
she's got to take that yeah now we don't
have c4 anymore i don't know
but i guess she has the d file maybe
push e4
unless he stops it he
doesn't know anything no he just sees
he sees my ideas way quicker than me by
the time i notice them he already knows
how to stop them
king f2 okay rook there i think king
does need to go to f2 though gotta trade
the rooks
i mean we're equal on time so oh no this
is a position i think alexandra can win
it's just
put that knight on d4 she's done it and
now you realize like
it's not easy at all to break through
with the bishops i think alexandra can
improve her king
move the knight from g3 maybe play h3 g4
h3g4 i like it no i think i think she
can do well in this position knights are
really nice to play with
siri went off she always okay
she's looking to participate as well
i mean you know with a.i and chess
stream siri might just be the next
big chess player oh
greg's rerouting i think she needs to
leave her king on f2 h3g4
yes we need there we go king f2
okay h3 h3 g4 she gonna do it
oh my goodness no she doesn't see the
plan
i think she's trying to occupy the holes
or something she doesn't really know
what to do like maybe
she's going back and forth which is fine
as long as she's not wasting too much
time
okay no not the plan you wanted but it's
a solid flynn
because the dark the darkest bishop
can't really get in and attack that v2
pawn so
she's got to keep this close okay so
she's just turtling she's saying look
yeah
i i respect i respect the turtle but
he has that file again we don't have
rook h1 oh my goodness
no no no no no knight f3 united three
knight f3 is a good move actually that
is a good one
g4 thank you okay she got out of it i
don't think you should have taken on
before it should have taken on g3
yeah i think black should have taken on
g3 didn't happen
okay take that back i see three i like
it she's she's coming out of the
darkness but two seconds oh my goodness
there's knight a4 as well knight she
could pretty much
before would have been a nice premium
yes okay quite fast there we go we just
need speed
take it home take the win oh but he
hasn't passed
the master doesn't matter
get the knights back yes take something
yes
yes geek there we go he dropped off now
she's got it
now she's got it he gobbling it all up
finally a bullet win we knew she had it
she just needed to break through
nice hey look at those juicy points
grayson
quite a lot of rating if he loses two
more you could go underneath 2500
well that is that's a big win for
alexander 19 to 17.
now andrea let's also remember this
match is getting close but look at the
time
yeah how much time do we have six and a
half minutes oh
wow two if she could win two in a row
yep that'd be fantastic but yeah
16 minutes is not much but you know it's
bullet that's plenty of games
yes six minutes oh sorry six minutes
yes yes so that is not a lot you said 16
no so there's six months never mind it's
okay we have time for two wins
yep she's well she's got exactly that
and she needs to do exactly that
come on just win the tune well at least
it's competitive you know
it's close okay and i don't mind this
you know what happened last time with
that okay file it
kind of worked out um before i don't
mind this for alexandra basically when
alexandra is attacking greg
i i always think she's gonna do a bit
better i agree for sure
h5 he is a very strong defender but
it's much better than her defending yep
yep brooke g8 threatens knight h4 yeah i
think
safe castle is a good idea here is to
avoid
as long as she and she's keeping her
time which is giving me lots of hope
yep i really like when she's attacking
she's getting good positions
good positions i like that move knight
age four threat h5 go go page five let's
go
looking good she's got a very good
position yes
now if h4 i think he's going to go g4
queen h3
i'm fine with that move aggressive no
i'm going to queen trade and take f5
with the knight beautiful attacking the
pawns
this is very good oh i thought she had
something really good there
was you got a tactic or something i
don't mind f6 b4 is hanging here as well
she's also got like just doubling the
ropes solid yep and that knight is very
strong
there's a really good play by alexandria
doubling the rooks it's looking good
knight back probably gonna bring the
rook back to g1 here
i was wondering here if she could play
knight h3 yep knight h3 you're right
very good tactic that actually would
have been fantastic attacking both the
rooks forcing rook to f1
and then she could brought rogue oh that
would have been rook two two and it
doesn't won the game
it's okay uh take it back she's still
got a great position
yeah she just has to activate her king
i think you can take away yeah she can
take on e4 because we're not worried
about the pin because we have knight c3
right or even check
he's thinking he's getting down he's
going down 10 seconds
alexandra activate the king maybe or she
wants to trade even
well has the file but let's just eat up
the pawns
yep i like that move this is good
you're gonna take one c4 she can grab
the pawn
she's used to trying to use the knight
to grab all makes sense because the rook
is important on f4 holding the king
there
and greg's going to go a5 next but oh
she's she's playing this really well
she is playing this really well you got
to watch fun oh this is so nice
one more pawn okay yeah she does have to
watch the h pawn for sure oh
king h3 she needs the night night in
the bring the knight yeah because the
rook doesn't have really enough time to
get behind the pawn
or does it end there we go there we go
all right so she's winning here she's
just four seconds though she has four
seconds i don't
i don't know mr mike plug run the pawn
nice nice
good now the rook can run h4 beautiful
she hung her knight that's okay she
slows chances king don't eat it
have enough pawns to win but one second
oh my god she's so close to flagging
okay she's back to three oh god
the time is making me so nervous oh my
gosh there's rook h3
check oh before it won the night oh no
no no it's a drama take the knight take
the knight
take the night five seconds oh no
no no take the knight take the gun
ignite and then check and then prepare
the queen but it's too late
oh my goodness check it out i don't know
what's gonna happen
he's gonna take a draw or something no
she's like probably still winning or
something yes yes
he has a lot of pawns oh gosh b4 before
it's main two
b4 no it was made in two oh
man oh no okay it's still
it's still not over it's still tied
looks tied
is she gonna be able to meet him king c3
very nice knight d5 he has
b3 b3 yes 25 or 94
b2 king b3 oh this is a draw
but she shouldn't take it technically
with the patch
yeah no he's gonna go for it she's gonna
go for a trick
she has to dang it i think i think that
means she's gonna lose the match
even though it's a tremendous game point
that's insane just because there's not
enough time
wow but you know even being one point
away is a pretty strong finish
wow wow that game guys i mean
you saw that was a great game andrea and
i was literally just screaming
because there were like maids miss
pieces
everywhere that's bullet though that's
why it's a lot of fun how much time do
we have on the timer
a minute and 20 seconds dang
yeah that's what i was saying bad games
unfortunately she had to win that yeah
yep she had her chances it's okay at
least if we
finish with a win a 0.5 difference
is not too bad yeah yeah greg
greg looks like he's gonna win this
match but
you know there's there's one more game
and alexandra ellis finished
wrong finish with dignity she's playing
really well right now
yes i i told you that the bullet i knew
was gonna be a strong suit but this is
so close
i think if there was no increment on the
bullet it would have been different
because she would have had her dirty
flags
yes but uh i don't know who would have
flagged first true i don't know
i know she's she has a lot of tricks up
her sleeves so does greg
so c3 uh kick the knight up bishop g5
coming in she's got a great position by
the way yep
yeah this is a fantastic guy i love it
her king is safe her rooks are well
placed
and her development is just great yeah
bishop g5
i love the position this is this is nice
um 97 and forcing the trade so that she
can bring a rook to the seventh rank
yep this looks really good do it right
now oh maybe
yeah 97. this is okay take with the
bishop maybe and try to win that pawn or
take her to the right
she could win ah there's not enough time
so i think the idea is like um c4 here
then to play bishop d5 check and bishop
h6 after king h8 and you have a very
almost checkmate
wow um but after
after c4 there is queen takes b2 so it's
nice
not so simple she wants to get her
bishop to d5
that would have been a fantastic she got
a stacked on g7 then push c4
and yeah
g7 bishop h6 get the bishop to d5 that's
oh my god
yeah bishop or rook back to e7 she's
trading
don't like that
okay okay uh king
up and now we do not want to trade
no trades uh not much of a choice
what oh now the king can easily defend
yeah so greg just has the upper hand
here in the end game
um up a pawn often in the end game
that's enough to win
yes especially when they both have the
bishop pair
and they'll they'll trade off and end up
with the same colored bishop
no chance for draw and there was a
moment there where greg could have just
repeated moves and taken a draw and won
the match
and he's like yeah he's like you know
what at the rate yeah
reading matters yeah that's very true
hey bishop c1 by alexandra
grandmaster move to finish off there we
go
nice i'm a fan bishop f1 maybe for the
fans
bishop f1 for the fans no okay she's
just avoiding all the bishop trades
makes sense
yep exactly what you should do yep
so now eventually she's gonna run out
the back and forth moves because yep
he's coming to attack
king b5 probably king a4 okay
there we go now the king is kind of cut
off from entering back
can you go around bishop c6 take on a5
no
they could have taken the pawn oh yeah
with with jeff yeah
or taking the bishop and then taking the
pawn
oh that would have been a nice draw or
maybe i'll
yeah he has three seconds alexander
could have maybe won that position yeah
this still can happen doubles you down
to kwanzaa whoa
bishop d6 is good interesting
but i'm defending the night's still
tough he's got one second by the way
yeah alexandra is very quick yes she
really is
looking good she might
put it she's keeping the pressure nice
a great move yeah maybe oh no why d1
okay she can't take on g6
she's gonna take eight and now she hey
okay we're gonna get a draw maybe
this is a probably a draw uh should be a
draw
but she's nearly trying to mate herself
king e2
yeah oh god oh no
that is a beautiful checkmate
to to end off a half wow
just half point everyone's saying oh
these odds
they're not fair clearly it was tied it
was very close
oh my goodness that that was a beautiful
checkmate yes that was great i i loved
the ending even though
i would have loved to see the rook sack
in c4 but
this is a great match i i knew it'd be
off to the bullet but greg
very well done to greg yeah that was
beautiful so
the match does finish uh 19 and a half
to 18 and a half
for uh international master greg shahadi
probably
as close as it could be greg was you
know careful not to go 16-0 handicap
because he wouldn't have won that in
that case that was insanely close
yeah oh i didn't realize there's a one
point difference i thought she had
oops i thought she had more never mind i
wasn't
yeah i know that but it's just i can't
do math i just thought she had another
win for some reason
no it's it's very close though it's just
one game and
after that exciting match uh we're
looking forward to getting into an
interview with the players but
before we do that just gonna take a
super short break to get that set up
and to give everyone a chance to cool
down after that you know adrenaline
packed
uh one minute section so andrea you and
i will be right back
after this short break with the
interview
and welcome back everybody we are joined
by the competitors in today's match
alexandra botes and greg shahadi
and andre and i were honestly on the
edge of our seats because
the the handicap that was given i'll go
to you first greg
honestly made it such a perfect match it
was so close in the end just one game
separating it is this handicap uh you
know do you have any idea what this 15
games was gonna mean like do you always
be this close
i really didn't know i thought i would
do well
in the first two sections um you did
and i go into the last one i think i was
what up one point or even or something
and i was like okay one minute chest
should be no problem and then at the end
she just starts
beating me then i'm getting checkmated
it won't let me move any pieces like the
king of stuff
and then i looked and i was like time as
i was like okay get me out of here yeah
thank goodness that that one point at
the end
alexandria you were mounting a pretty
serious comeback in the bullet portion
and
i think uh andre and i were both
agreeing that as the time got shorter
your your chances of winning were going
to get higher did you feel the same way
coming into this match
uh i i i told greg that i was really
nervous coming to this match i felt like
i was going to get kind of wiped
off the board but at least the bullet
portion wasn't as bad i mean i hope i
scared greg a little bit you know that's
all i can hope
for i'm terrified
i was so happy i don't know how much
time was left and then you could be i
was like oh my god
what's happening and then i looked and i
was like okay i mean
i was scared yeah andrea do you have any
uh
anything you'd like to say to your
sister after she represented house
uh botes there do you think cameron
would be proud
after that match i think the one
win in the five minute or three minute
section that he prepared me in that one
line he
must be yeah
yeah i promised hammer i wouldn't let
him down and i did
where you will have a chat oh man that's
this is a this is a serious interview
all of a sudden alexander is going to
get chatted to after
oh yeah well that was a beautiful game
though the the one that
you're talking about um uh there was
actually some
serious prep remembered there by
alexandra and that game was actually
quite important for the match because it
gave you a lot of confidence i thought
and going into the bullet i think people
kind of underestimated maybe
what what you could do in the bullet
section was quite impressive
alexandra but i'm going to ask you
what's on the tip of everyone's tongue
right now
uh did you guys coordinate outfits
during that
or you know what's what's going on that
was so coordinated alexandra greg helped
me out here oh it was all improvising
improvisation like once you did the
thing with the hat i'm just like i'm
changing my outfit every year i like
that greg would always
match respect greg you pulled out the
mask
frankie's super fashionable he brought
out the blazer so i had to bring one out
also you know if i can't beat him in
chess
at least match him in his fashion i
don't know if the the future opponents
are going to be
changing outfits as much as alex but i
hope so
i hope so we got a lot of different
looks from you guys we got
masks we got the hat the workout attire
there was plenty
i was i think oh go on greg i gotta do a
quick workout in between the three
minute and one minute section that's why
yeah yeah you were wearing your muscle
tank top we're like was he working out
before this alex only brought out the
dumbbell once maybe that was the whole
one game decisive because he was
exercising a little bit more that's
because you are streaming and i was
kicked out of my own house and i'm
playing in a little
conference room and i got to go all the
way up to go to the bathroom i don't
have time to exercise
that's true that's true
i heard andrea giving behind the scenes
advice to alexandra
you know during the breaks and it was
something to the effect of
alexandra just don't blunder tactics and
you'll win
no i said very wise words
i said don't go for tricks play solid
but you know it means the same thing
yeah yeah just don't lose in your win
exactly exactly just don't blend with
that
better at tactics like you can't just
change your style
yeah greg's tactics were super sharp
greg
thank you do you do a lot of puzzles
i've been doing some puzzle rush lately
that's what we're lacking yeah my image
of greg
is him doing crossfit and then doing
like five
chest and then a couple more reps
yeah that's that's like pretty act well
now that's everyone's you've been
watching my workout routine
you know i am greg i'm taking notes
well you practically did one uh on cam
for us here so we couldn't help it
we couldn't help it now greg the the end
result was you know i got to say
congratulations you did come away
with a victory against alexandria so you
will move on
to the next round in this tournament um
now you've you've got some experience in
this event before so you played in the
last
i am not a gm tournament um and this
time around it's a little bit different
it's not all ims it's
some popular faces streamers um what do
you think that does
to the nature of the event because
already we saw how much fun
it was to have a handicap and you are
ever the entertainer
first i want to say one thing um if you
look at the bracket there's one name
that's not there
there's one scared player that knew he
was going to get whooped this year
like i'm not playing i don't want any
piece of greg shahadi you know who that
is right
mr john bartholomew and that's one game
i played with handy in his honor just to
be like you know
you didn't play the scandi like the
whole match against me i'm going to play
it
to show you you know like i'm not a
chicken
that's all i want to say yeah harsh
words for john
and uh yeah a lot of i love that danny
wrench lawrence trent match that's going
to be amazing
ooh yeah yeah that was one of my
highlights as well
uh an underrated matchup danny against
lawrence is going to be some
some heat behind that one yeah a lot of
matches coming up
andrea do you have any uh anything you
wanna i know you're gonna have your talk
with with alex so maybe you're saving
your questions for office i'll
save my words for alex but greg well
played
i love that thank you congratulations on
winning the match and good luck in the
next matchup
thank you very much thanks so much for
everything great match alex it was fun
yeah greg i had a lot of fun uh thanks
for this i know i know you're obviously
the much better player but it
whenever i have a match like this it
makes me want to play more chess and
study more so i appreciate
it you're a very strong player so you
play a lot of really good games
especially in the end of that bullet
and you know like early in the five
minute there was some tough like the
second game the fourth game they were
like time scrambles i was like i'm gonna
lose the second game
but i didn't somehow yeah it was like
pulled it off yeah somehow
the uh the result ended in greg's favor
but i agree that the games that we saw
and the way we were commentating the
time scrambles i mean we didn't know
what was gonna happen so
thanks to both of you greg
congratulations again alexandra
thank you so much that was a truly
entertaining match and i think i speak
for andrea
the chat everyone uh watching that we
really had a great time so
um ggs and we'll see you in the next
round greg
yeah thank you thanks andreas thanks bye
everyone
all right bye guys and uh that is
gonna be our uh our coverage here
for the i i'm not a gm tournament
um chess.com puzzle week don't forget
that is starting tomorrow
you know in terms of chess.com events
and what to look forward to
that's coming right up so if you if you
didn't get enough chess today
don't worry we got you covered for
tomorrow and uh
andrea the the chess.com arena kings
also gets underway the week after that
so
you know if you're basically looking to
just get immersed in chess.com events i
think it's fair to say we got the people
covered
yes there's definitely some very
exciting events coming up and i will be
watching the puzzle one because
both alex and i need the practice
yeah so puzzles coming up that's
starting tomorrow it's gonna be a lot of
fun as i mentioned lots of
different formats that we're gonna get
into uh andrea i mean
did it hurt a little bit watching your
sister go down on you know on
live twitch tv you know i knew that greg
had very good odds so overall i'm pretty
proud because
it was a very close very close matchup
so i'm proud with how it ended
yeah and speaking of how it ended you
know she got a beautiful checkmate there
on the board so hey you can't complain
it was a match that greg was the
favorite in
uh ever the entertainer he he put up a
handicap and it was a super close match
and uh you know congrats to him but i
think uh
he'll be looking forward to his next
match and we'll be looking forward to
to commentating uh future matches so
it's been a pleasure today thanks for
yeah it was great um thank you so much
for being a great partner and i will be
cheering greg on in the future rounds
i'm a big greg fan after this commentary
for sure
awesome well thanks for hanging out with
us guys we're done for the day
thanks for watching the coverage of greg
shahadi versus alexandra botes in the
i'm
not a gm tournament and this tournament
is going to be going on
for uh months actually there's going to
be lots of matches
keep in touch uh always stay following
the channel there's gonna be lots of
coverage
and puzzle week starts next week so
without further ado andrea
thanks again and uh bye everybody see
you next time thank you i'm on bye
everybody
you